[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
look at this pretty hair kids oh [__]
dressed up
for [__] fat man beyond welcome to
fat man beyond I'm Kevin Smith I'm Mark
Bernardin hey
uh if you're wondering why this uh is
because I literally just came from a
photo shoot a Jay and Silent Bob photo
shoot and uh that's why I may look made
up as well
uh I don't normally make myself up nor
do I [__] normally look at that kids
it's that simple there there's your
childhood
[__] lies nothing but lies I was just
talking to my friend before about
um I don't know if I'm supposed to say
this yet
there's a well [__] it there's a um a
muppet show that's coming to Disney plus
uh I'm up in Mayhem called Muppet Mayhem
very good uh from Adam Goldberg and I
may or may not
have been on set and whatnot but I was
talking about how being around
The Muppets
um was like you know I'm [__] now a
hardened professional in this here
entertainment business and you know I've
met [__] famous people and [__] like
that Legends and but you know once you
know how the sausage is made maybe the
magic loses a little bit of its flavor
but I was reduced to [__] childhood
when I was on set with Muppets because
it's still
it's not like animation where it's just
like you know oh my God [__] I love
these characters and they're like well
then you'll see them in nine months to a
year because that's how long it takes
when you're with the Muppets
they they are alive
the moment a hand goes up the ass and
most of these cats have been doing it
for like ever
keep them on so like you'll be having a
conversation with the person who works
the Muppet but they keep the Muppet
going
so like you're talking to a human and
the Muppets alive in the conversation
you keep like I'm not even talking about
when they have the Muppet talk to you
you're just talking to the muppeteer and
they're still
doing this [__] looking around and you
feel like there's a third party that
you're having a conversation with and
it's absolutely
[__] magical like and and so low Tech
you're talking about one of the oldest
art forms on the planet right like
[__] a puppet For Heaven's Sake but
my god it works like [__] crazy man
um hopefully it's not lost on The Tick
Tock generation I hope them up and still
have as much [__] Magic
for like a kid today as they did for us
do you think do you think they do Mark
you know I I'm not sure I I remember
feeling very kind of old and crestfallen
when the Muppets and Sesame Street moved
to HBO which they did for a while
and like I felt like no they're still
there yeah like I felt like you could
find the episodes that got rid of half
the episodes or some sort of [__] yeah I
I felt as if we failed them like they
were giving us a public good and all we
had to do was once a year buy a [__]
tote bag and we didn't buy enough
[__] tote bags
and suddenly they needed the patronage
of daddy Warner Brothers to make the
Muppets go and he's like what it was
free it was a public good it was ours
anybody could watch it it would make me
cry
and yeah we didn't just get enough
shitty [__] umbrellas from the Helena
Rubenstein Foundation to make
Rubinstein Foundation
um
kids we're old men talking about old men
[__] the moment you hear a [__]
middle-aged man talking about how we
failed The Muppets you know that we're
buggy you're watching Batman Beyond kids
welcome back it's been a red hot minute
last time we did this we were live at
spod Castle Baxter Ides of Markham what
a [__] great time that was
um but since then so many things have
happened tell them where you went I was
in New Orleans for the Overlook Film
Festival
um showing a little picture called
splinter
um which was what a wonderful experience
that was
um I mean we played the pan-african film
festival here in La which was great but
I always feel like film festivals in
your hometown are a bit like Comic Cons
in your hometown
which is it's not quite as special
because it's not a destination like you
don't go to that place and invest in
that place for three or four days you go
home every night right
um but going to overlook which is all
about horror and all about genre and it
being in New Orleans and New Orleans
being a spooky [__] City anyway
um it was just so much fun and it was so
supportive and everybody there was
really welcoming to the short they had
nothing but lovely things to say about
it and uh and it was just it was great
and spending four days in New Orleans is
automatically a good time
uh Tiffany our dear friend uh Tiffany
Smith who was there with you indeed sent
uh photos and [__] I couldn't get
information out of [__] Mark
he was busy being a [__] celebrity
director and [__] but Tiffany was like
uh she was texting me being like
greetings from from New Orleans and
stuff the picture her Mark I was like oh
my God how to play she said through the
roof and then she sent a picture of like
a [__] packed house watching a movie
and stuff now when we did fat man beyond
its mod Castle
after the show was over Mark showed it
and [__] and one of my favorite moments
in smog Castle thus far
um has been for those of you who are
like what the [__] is podcast that's the
movie theater smart Castle Cinemas that
I own with my friends back in Jersey
um one of my favorite moments that has
happened at the theater since we took it
over in October
didn't even involve me it was sitting in
the back of the theater and cucking out
on Mark while he was up doing a q a that
just wouldn't end it went on for like an
hour and the time we started the movie
it was like [__] almost been I think
we were we went to midnight or past
midnight but like people had great
questions and [__] Mark was holding
court and answer him and [__] and I was
like oh that's my man right up there it
was so sweet and normally like you know
I'm a man who appreciates q a it's like
how I made my bones in this business but
watching somebody else Ascend with q a
was in my own theater was wonderful how
was the Q and A's in uh New Orleans as
they say um I mean they were good but
when you're part of a shorts program
which we were they just
um everybody is up there as part of the
Q a so it's like me and the Splinter
team and then the writer directors of
the other five or six shorts that are
there so it's less an intensive hour
long
um sort of Investigation of a movie and
more just kind of a glistening off the
surface kind of chat uh a round table as
it were with a bunch of other people
which was still great because earlier
the shorts were really interesting and
very well done and all the other
filmmakers were super great
um and smart and sharp and funny and and
now it's lovely man like there was no
part of it that wasn't a good time and
every shorts block we were in it sold
out
oh [__] hey well done yeah I'm not
gonna say it's our fault but it's our
fault
did it you made it happen the um in uh
uh chat uh long story short uh Austin uh
Harley's boyfriend who was in Clark's
three played uh
um blockchain Coltrane
um I was over my kid's house
that's right my kid has a [__] house
if that don't make you feel [__] old
um
and my kid like [__] lives
on YouTube on her big on her TV I was
gonna say big TV but
it's not as big as my TV but on her TV
she don't [__] with it on her phone or
her laptop that's what she watches she
don't watch television and [__] she
watches YouTube on her TV and her
favorite thing in the world that runs
constantly
on [__] a never-ending Loop are
videos of people walking around
Disneyland
there's a whole [__] sub Market of
this [__] including Peter sharetta who
runs slash film and has like creative
slash film ran it for [__] years
Peter schrad is the one that took me to
see
uh The Dark Knight for a press screening
[__] like when the Dark Knight came
out and [__]
but Peter schrett has got a side hustle
I don't even know about where him and
his lady just [__] go to Disney and
make videos all the time about [__]
things at Disney they're massive Disney
fans so my kid like I remember at one
point like she was I was like Woody why
are you always on YouTube and she showed
me she's like I love these videos and I
was like I know that [__] man
that's the guy to run slash home she
goes no that's the guy who does whatever
[__] it's called whatever her show is
and this is what the kid lives for is
these [__] videos of people that go
to Disneyland and literally just shoot
the entire experience like we watched
one video where guys like this is
Indiana Jones from [__] years ago
this is the Indiana Jones ride with a
new paint job and like goes through the
whole ride holding the [__] camera
walks through the whole park she was
watching a series of videos of like
Toontown they reopened and [__] did
new things to it and [__] so anyway
we watched you know I was like hey man
if you're gonna put if you're gonna
watch something on YouTube what about
your old man and [__] like that and
she's like what do you mean I'm like I
can't believe I got a kid don't even
know I'm on [__] I said I do [__]
show all the time and it was right after
we had done the live show from
smodcastle so I said [__] here give
me that and I [__] typed in our show
and Austin her boyfriend was a big
YouTuber back in the day and [__] like
he just lived for that [__] so he was
like oh my God look at how many [__]
views you have and you don't you're not
[__] monetizing it correctly you
don't even have super chat I was like
what's that
and so he went in and changed all the
[__] settings and [__] and put us up
on Super Chat which Super Chat is
apparently
people like can [__] give money to
ask questions and [__] so long story
short
will Wilkins who uh of course is dilf
man Banff man won't be with us today
because Banff man is in the UK going to
Celebration right now but we got a
special report from Bam Bam which we'll
get to in a minute uh dilfman will
Wilkins who took over you know when when
uh JC couldn't do a show before is doing
the the show today jump on in here dilf
man
and he [__] put a bucket what's up
dilf man hello
um thank you for that [__] dollar my
friend yeah oh that was a dude who just
asked a ten dollar question why talking
to the one dollar again where's the ten
dollar question I'm sure if you scroll
back through it you'll see oh you're
gonna be close oh my God Joshua Mundo
yeah Kevin did you receive a delivery
Friday that was not for Jen's birthday
was it flowers if so yes a gigantic
[__] bouquet of flowers that I had to
explain to my wife
was not from like she was like who are
you [__] and I was like I'm not
[__] Josh mundle I swear if that was
it it was for me and my mom thank you my
mom's in the hospital right now so if
that's what it is yes and then he said
Mark did you go to Ricardo's dookie
chases or Floyd's to eat while in New
Orleans to answer his question because
he paid [__] nine bucks 10 bucks so I
must ask a question and I feel like this
is somehow this is going to be the end
of the show as we know it
like suddenly we're building like an
aristocracy suddenly there's a one
percent of question askers exactly Mark
and so it's no longer just a like I
asked a good question I'm in the feed
they'll notice and I was like excuse me
sir here's my shiny ten dollar piece for
these gentlemen never mind the rebel I
want to know something first anyway
Joshua I did not eat in any of those
places
um I went to coops uh coops bar in uh in
in the quarter I went to Parkway for uh
my Po Boys
um and then I kind of like and of course
I went to to um
Kevin demand for beignets but other than
that it was a little bit catches to
catch Canada the festival had me moving
so I didn't get a chance to kind of
wallow in the French Quarter as I
usually do uh Bijou who did not pay for
a Super Chat question so just to prove
to you that we're still dealing with the
plebes as well kids we're not like
[__] icing anybody yeah but Bijou
said super chat but YouTube takes 30 of
every contribution so we're never going
to get rich doing this [__] show
never ever ever so Austin God bless him
he thought this would change everything
is bricks goes here's ten dollars dance
monkey dick damn skippy I don't give a
[__] how many years I've been working in
entertainment and [__] or if I were for
Netflix or not 10 bucks is still [__]
10 bucks I grew up in an era where 10
bucks was like everything I'm a 70s kid
so if somebody throws me 10 [__]
bucks you better damn skippy they're
gonna be I'm gonna be like this way uh
sir like trust me Logan I still
appreciate the value of a book in any
event
Super Chat is on if you're into that
[__] believe me you don't have to Super
Chat us and stuff [__] Daddy Warbucks
roll it in go buy me a fine fat
man to me this question I love the
mixture of [__] two
childhood Classics of Dickens and any
any itself Daddy Warbucks
um kids
this is fat man beyond and we haven't
done it in a month so you'll excuse our
[__] excitement I guess not fight a
month I guess we did it Ides of March
was Mark was the 15th 16th I think we
did it on the 17th so it's only April
10th so we missed it by a week being a
month between shows but as you heard
with good reason Mark at one point was
in New Orleans did you [__] with that
spooky house that they had in American
Horror Story That's like ice country
right there I do not [__] with spooky
houses man like they had a whole like
immersive kind of experience where even
like going to this hotel room and do
this thing and have a seance and
whatever it's like nope I'm good I don't
I don't need I don't I don't have a good
time getting scared so and I don't want
to be scared in real life so like I went
with one person it wasn't even an escape
room it was some like slightly immersive
thing and I just spent the entire 20
minutes looking for the seams so that I
could be like all right this isn't real
this isn't real I don't have to punch
anybody that's fine because if somebody
[__] touches me in a dark hotel room
I'ma punch him so like the people pay
good [__] money get touched in a dark
hotel room man you're just looking to
give towards them out holy [__] [__] all
that we got pounds bro
pound sterling man Lewis Burridge says I
give you my shiny money and ask how
Splinter is going down can't wait to see
it answer that man's question mark he
gave us 10 [__] pounds that's got to
be worth like a hundred dollars American
I just gotta say I agree with Mark this
is not a good thing
it's automatically got off their manuals
it'll be we'll do this for one week and
then probably never again but still
nothing's happening the floor is yours
Lewis Burridge sir Louis I'll tell you
uh the Splinter is going down very very
well incredibly smooth
um we are at the point now where I think
we are going to finally fulfill all of
our Kickstarter obligations and send the
short to everybody who helped us make
the short
um you know we we wanted to give the the
festival sort of space it's time to to
have it exclusively we've done so
um we're going to be hopefully fingers
crossed bringing to Comic-Con
um so if any anybody is a Comic-Con want
to see if they can do so and if that's
the case then yeah like it's time to
just [__] drop the link in some
emails and let the 2700 people who
helped us make it finally see what they
paid for now what can they [__] like
throw that up on YouTube or no uh it'll
probably be via Vimeo a little bit more
protected than uh than YouTube is that
was my question even though here we are
on YouTube we're talking about how
unsafe
it ain't unsafe anymore we got pound
sterling answer your question oh bro
they're stacking up like Jets here man
there's a 15 question that's a 20
question 9.99 another one but hey the
[__] man no I'm kidding well all
questions about while we're here uh
Twisted films you're right this is the
end of the [__] show for 15 [__]
bucks man I'm trying to win the lottery
so I can hire you and Mark to help me
make my Tom Waits based movie think
Stand By Me but with Tom Waits and red
Sabine
I went silent because of [__] red
Sabine I mean look we all love Tom Waits
and [__] but like red Sabine who talks
about Red Sovine this day and age
films I hope you [__] get that money
because I know two dudes that'll help
you out
uh
20 question from Nick X Dillinger says I
open my wallet please open your dot dot
dot mouth [__] whatever you want man
you asked a 20 question Nick that's
[__] real money and [__] uh Dart car
for 11 bucks says Hey guys love the show
how did Ezra and thrawn survive the jump
into hyperspace with the windows blown
out what a good question I mean [__]
we're going to talk about celebration
and we're going to talk about that
Ahsoka trailer which essentially looks
like Rebels part two and [__]
um how I don't know I don't even know
how to answer that question bro
somebody just asked a 49 question what
the [__] I mean [__] making movies this
is what I'm gonna do for the rest of my
life
answer questions for money man [__] this
is the best thing that ever happened to
me ever I'll give a [__] if it is the
end of the show this is a good thing uh
I don't know how they escape but I bet
you Mark has a guess how did Ezra and
thrawn survive the jump in hyperspace
with the windows blown out I have no
[__] idea I've never seen Rebels so I
yeah that's a legit answer right there
my guess
the force there you go I mean it's smart
let's let's [__] find out what
somebody wants to know for 49 how the
[__] does that happen I can't even find
there you are oh it's Josh mondall man
Kevin did you give Jay and Jordan the
grogu outfit gift oh [__] that's our boy
who is at [__] The Ides of Mark who
was like if you show [__] Excalibur
on June 21st I'm there because that's my
birthday remember he was the one who was
right right up front she came all the
way from Austin he had signs to go the
show he had signs he was our Let's Make
a Deal guy that's what it said in the
card the card that came with the flowers
that said I'm the Let's Make a Deal Sign
guy and I was going like the look did I
buy Let's Make a Deal sign now I'm
putting it all together and [__] I can't
wait to get off the show so I can tell
my wife I know who those [__] flowers
came from and yes I am having an affair
with him uh he came all the way from
[__] Austin to go to to uh The Ides
of Mark and he also went of course to
Fountain in Beyond The Lodge show but he
had come to see The Muppets when when I
did the movies that made me the bumpit
movie and [__] and I wasn't there
because I was away something that I'll
be talking about in the near future and
whatnot
um but yes did I give Jay and join the
grogu outfit gift absolutely I did
oh my God Josh stop paying money to ask
answer ask questions like that that's
way too much money but thank you I feel
like 79 [__] bucks Jesus man I feel
like a cam girl
right this is so hot dude uh eleven
dollars what do you want to see yeah
I'll show you Ted I'm gonna [__] uh Ed
gave us five pounds [__] Sterling to
say Kevin and Mark you make me so happy
you make me happy [__] uh DG
gave me four dollars and twenty cents
420 said enough said
class right there Gabriel Lopez for 20
bucks is Kevin your thoughts on season
three of Mando so far love you and
thanks for the inspiration
um I I'm honestly I've enjoyed it I know
a lot of folks have had issues and [__]
like that and they're like why isn't
this show about the Mandalorian anymore
but I legit love that one episode that
was all about Dr Pershing
um and I do love Boca tan so I like that
they've been following her storyline and
whatnot we'll talk more about the
Mandalorian in a red hot minute and
stuff but Gabriel Lopez
[__] a oh my God
the prescription hipster for 17 bucks is
Hey Kevin what's going on with Muse
moose Jaws delayed till you are free or
canceled
I mean [__] I hope it's not the latter
um yeah it's just been delayed honestly
Lion's gate the good folks that we've
been in business with you know they did
our home video for Jay and Sal and Bob
reboot and they produced all the [__]
clerks three smart bless him Mark you
want to just go grab some food we can
leave him here doing this for a little
while no no it's cool
we'll get to everybody I should stop
looking yeah stop super chatting us kids
for a red hot minute we have so much
show to get to but they Alliance gate
was like what else you got and I was
like I want to do this movie called
Moose Jaws they're like what is it I
says it's Jaws but with a moose instead
of a shark and they were like how much
is it I was like three million bucks
they're like we'll make five of them so
I'm like oh [__] so it's now just
stacked up like Jets waiting for me to
get there man I I think for sure we're
gonna start the 4 30 movie which is the
next book I want to direct
um we shoot it in my movie theater spot
Castle Cinemas
um in the beginning of September after
the summer movie season is done looks
like we're gonna start shooting the
movie like hopefully September 1st and
[__] then there's another thing that
just happened today which I can't talk
about which came out of the [__] blue
kids and I I didn't even expect we'd
ever make this movie but suddenly it
looks like oh [__] we are going to make
this movie I'll talk about that way down
the road man
um so thank you prescription hipster uh
God damn it this is so [__] fun
bonanista says Uh Kevin are you and Muse
going to continue the father podcast yes
we absolutely are what a great question
he's supposed to come over this week for
us to record an episode uh we've been
he's been more busy than me because Jay
Muse became a [__] father uh his
second child uh Lucian was born like two
months ago or whatever [__] adorable
[__] kid and Muse is like one of the
most adventurous fathers I ever saw he
holds the kid in his palm on his arm he
goes look at this he goes like this [__]
and I hate being around him and his kid
because I'm like no but he's you know
parents know what they're doing and [__]
he's such a great dad so yes we will be
continuing fatherhood uh thg universe is
Kevin have you had time to watch retro
freaks yet Dave Ryan and this just came
out of the sequels budget retro freaks
is a movie that played very well mind
you at smodcast Castle Cinemas uh and he
gave me a copy to watch uh the truth is
no I have not I've been dealing with
some [__]
um
including my mom is in the hospital I
was in Florida all last week uh she's
actually moved a step closer toward
Improvement and stuff she they've been
keeping her like [__] sedated like
[__] she intubated with the tube down
her throat and she's got another tube up
her nose pumping out her stomach and
[__] like that long story short don't
get old kids I know the alternative
sucks but my God it's 77 is
heartbreaking but look we're not here to
talk about that and break hearts and
[__] uh oh my God you're right this is
going to destroy the show Patrick quill
for five bucks says love your movies
Kevin thank you for making them I love
you Patrick well
um big fan of your [__] cousin's work
I'm sorry I'm going to
it's destroying the show already isn't
it yeah um
have them bid up for the Q a spot that's
what you do tell them [__] dope man
that's a good idea tell them I just did
I know but put it into better words than
just you should sell them your super
chats for the end of the show during the
Q a session
there's a guy there's a guy who's
thinking and that's a producer
[__] YouTube well [__] will does a
show on YouTube called nut heads and
he's done it for a thousand years so
will is also a YouTuber who understands
a thing or two about a thing or two
thank God he's here this week and not
Banff man because Batman would be too
busy [__] blowing Star Wars and [__]
like that at least [__] dilf man
could say something smart like that
however from blacks the poodle gave us
Bruno bullax the poodle gave us 37 bucks
just to say in a row that's class right
there come on man that's awesome
um okay uh sad boy gave us [__] 4.99
Savoy 1984 pound sterling I don't know
why I get excited for money from one he
said thanks for making Mall Rats was
that the was the first that made me feel
like I belonged oh my God you're gonna
make me [__] cry man like that's
legit that's a legit compliment
um all right no more Super Chat man we
gotta concentrate on the [__] show
like [__] dilfman said before he
disappeared and [__]
um save up your [__] Super Chat money
for when we get to the question and
answer part then you can [__] like
then we might do more than three [__]
questions if everyone's paying for this
[__] and you can buy our favor this is
the episode where we jumped the sharks
at me however me and Mark are gonna make
an extra 100 to [__] jump that shark
man it's gonna be worth it we don't give
a [__] my favorite part of the show had
always been Kevin reads the chat a lot
[Music]
it's true I have to [__] stop oh my
god dude King Ethan just paid us 49.99
he said Kevin and Mark no question just
wanted to say thank you for the content
he flew from Florida to LA to visit JC's
bar in September of 2022. he had a blast
he drank two wakanda Forevers safe
travels to JC from London love you guys
King Ethan
the [__] man like my liege uh thank you
so much have a [__] sweet
um kids stop stop paying money though I
feel [__] guilty this sounded like a
cute idea but now I'm like real [__]
money man
you could just do a stream where you say
it's q a guys for an hour she's gonna be
me ask me what you want super [__]
Chatters get to the top of the list
otherwise I'm here for an hour
you don't even have to do a real [__]
show did you just hear my [__] brain
snap as I realized that you're
absolutely right oh my God [__] my
life has changed today as a [__]
Super Chat I am all I know I don't know
how to make movies you ask any critic
they'll [__] tell you all I know how
to do
is is [__] answer questions that's
all I've been doing for the last nearly
30 years I've trained for this moment
man the moment where somebody's like
I'll give you fifty dollars to ask you a
question like oh my God I'm ready for
that uh but we gotta do a show so let's
jump into the show we gotta do a show
there's some [__] that had dropped in
the internet there's some [__] that
we've both seen in the world I figured
we'll cover that or read an ad and then
we'll get into some Star Wars goodness
shall we do the ad first
I don't know will is it too early for
the ad or no dilf man tell us tell us
what to do
we've had an hour of questions from
Super Chat I think we're good this is
definitely what we would call mid-roll
so we're mid we can't escape it we're
mid [__] I wanted to be what's the
opposite of mid
uh
did his middle
mid is Middle yeah a lot of people are
like just showing even that anymore now
you just [__] answered super chat
questions we'll be Apex yeah we're Apex
well you know we ain't no Predators I
was about to say Predators but [__]
that's a horrible thing to say uh kids
this show wouldn't be happening
we're not for our sponsors although now
the game has changed man sponsors we
could have super Chatters paying for
this whole [__] Affair uh but but one
of the [__] sponsors who have stayed
with this show
through thick and thin ladies and
gentlemen uh are the good folks are good
friends at native
uh you know we love native and stuff uh
while we're talking about them uh give
your skin the protection it deserves
with natives mineral sunscreens go to
nativedeo.com Fatman right now or use
the promo code Fatman at checkout to get
20 off your first order that's
nativedeo.com Fatman or use the promo
code Fatman at checkout
nativedeo.com famine or use the promo
code Fatman I always begin the
commercial with the end of the
commercial so that people could follow
along by going to that website and ship
but let's talk about [__] native I
literally put some native deodorant on
today before I went to [__] do the
Jane Silent Bob shoot bam I use the
products that we talk about for heaven's
sakes and I know Mark does as well
absolutely I love anything that makes me
smell like something you want to eat man
and Native does this [__] all the time
you can smell like sugar cookies you can
smell it candy canes you can smell like
[__] flat out candy that's what they
did last month but today we're talking
about
this I love the feeling of soaking up
the sun this time of year
do I
I mean I hike running all the time so
[__] like I don't I guess I never
thought about it but I do look you look
healthy you look like you've been
outside in the sun well number one I
have but number two this may be makeup I
I don't know no no you got a nice uh you
got a nice glow to you well I was in
Florida and I was [__] going I did
the three mile walk around this lake
with my brother every day that I was
there and then since I got back I've
been hiking running as per usual running
Canyon is like literally right outside
my house and stuff so it's a Four Mile
Walk door to door and historically Mark
I've never [__] used uh sunscreen I
will now though native
sunscreen with all that time in the sun
I'm always worried about protecting my
skin Kevin Smith said from his own
imagination not from copy uh but with
Native sunscreen I could give my skin
the protection it needs and soak up some
much needed Sun natives quickly
absorbing ultra sheer hydrating and
lightweight sunscreen formula offers
broad spectrum SPF 30 protection from
UVA UVA and UVB rays man I actually
should start using this [__] to be
honest with you because I more than I
ever do go ahead as one of our Caucasian
Americans you absolutely should
thank you but as one of these Caucasian
Americans I've always tried to be up
like white Irish pale so you know it'd
be nice to have any sort of complexion
other than translucent whatnot so when I
go out I never think about putting on
sunscreen but I will now because I trust
the [__] good Folks at Native man
they have not done me wrong with [__]
body wash [__] shampoo with [__]
deodorant and [__] like that native is
amazing so that being said man all
Native sunscreen is made of a 20 active
zinc oxide formula that is dermatologist
tested and suitable for sensitive skin
like supposedly mine is all Native
sunscreen is made with oils derived from
Plants said this vegan uh that's seal
and don't get on my [__] about being
vegan I almost died of a heart attack
five years ago you probably didn't hear
about it because I never [__] talk
about it
um plants that's that seal in skin
moisture and is vegan and cruelty free
cruelty free we like as well we love
animals we're not animal haters here and
[__]
one of us is an animal eater but [__]
you know because I don't like them they
just happen to be delicious exactly he
loves an animal but he just he loves it
a little too much if they can taste
worse then I'd be down to not eat them
thank you
uh choose from one of native's three
delicious but subtle scents like coconut
and pineapple Rose or Sweet Peach and
nectar for your face or body or try
native's unscented option [__] that I'd
be putting pineapple all over my face
coconut pineapple those are two things
that come from the earth that I can
[__] get behind man it actually put
in my goddamn mouth because I'm a vegan
but I hate [__] things that grow out
of the Earth
um they I said please mention your
favorite scent mine is [__] pineapple
and coconut right there with all Native
sunscreen you get protection from the
Sun that is free of chemical actives uh
oxybenzone and oxygen OCTA octanoxate
that sounds like a villain [__]
Marvel comic
um I can't believe I said Marvel
really I know well sometimes I deal with
[__] that don't come from our world
and [__] you got to be like a Marvel
comic book and like oh I've heard of
Marvel and [__]
um Apple benzone [__] all that which
makes native sunscreen compliant with
the Hawaii act 104 which was passed in
an effort to protect Hawaii's reefs come
on man native's doing the Lord's work
over here man call the action kids give
your skin the protection it deserves of
natives mineral sunscreens go to
nativedeo.com Fatman or use the promo
code Fatman at checkout to get 20 off
your first order man that that's
nativedeo.com Fatman or use the promo
code Fatman at checkout
nativedeo.com
Fatman say it with me kids
Fatman winky dinky dog or use the promo
code fat man kids we thank the good
Folks at Native for sponsoring this show
although
[__] now that Super Chat lives and
there's a 99 Super Chat Jesus
a hundred dollars somebody asked to
[__] ask a question with olive oil
voices and proper pole dancing charm you
too Can Make It Rain Paper Chasing in
Hollywood without even having to work
the boulevards that's from Joshua mundle
Josh stop paying [__] legitimate
American dollars to [__] say [__] you
could just say [__] and I'll [__]
read it man
that's nuts that's a lot of money 100
bucks man Josh must be [__] rich I
don't know why I'm [__] asking
Studios for money I'm gonna ask Munhall
for some of that [__] sweet Mund Hall
money and [__] Super Chat me something
man how much people keep pay me to keep
Super Chat on because I found out I have
access to the on and off button
other than that you could kill it or or
more to the point I can enable it when
we really need it during the show
what a good point man uh Hey man CA 69
99 that means Canadian right yeah Daryl
Benz from Canada
one of my favorite [__] countries on
the planet says thoughts on Picard
season three and thanks for what you
guys do you guys make me laugh you're
the card guy give it to him I am and
that was actually one of the things I
wanted to talk about so thank you for
offering us a lovely segue into
the podcast we were supposed to be doing
I would say it like that [__] people
are paying real money man why don't you
hold that thought though because instead
of people subscribing to Super Chat
Kevin maybe you could tell them other
ways they could spend time with you for
their money at small Castle Cinemas or
this weekend at Flappers in Burbank
Jeff's kiss [__] you are a
producer dilf man
Banff man is just [__] all over Star
Wars [__] Johnson and [__] stealth
Man actually coming in producing we got
to have them both on the show Banff man
and then dilfman can come in to actually
[__] make sure that we're doing [__]
we should be doing kids do you want to
[__] see me in the real world uh if
you're in Los Angeles I spend a lot of
time in Jersey now so a lot of people
see me at smog Castle we'll talk about
that in a minute but you know for years
I've been out here 21 22 years I've been
living out in Hollywood and [__]
and you know we used to do live podcast
[__] Galore we used to do Hollywood
Babylon every goddamn week Jane Sal and
Bob get old every [__] week uh but
now it's a rare Bird a rare bird that's
a look like a bird yeah sure maybe it
should be this better thank you it was a
funny tree yes it's a rare tree a rare
Venus flytrap uh when I get to do a show
here in Los Angeles but don't you
[__] touch that dial because this
Saturday at Flappers Comedy Club me and
Ralph Garman gonna be doing Hollywood
Babylon the show we've been doing for 12
almost 13 years at this point kids uh we
had a great old time the last show we
did we were supposed to do a show in
March uh but then I had a thing and I
couldn't get back to Los Angeles so we
moved the show to April 15th so that's
this Saturday man at Flappers Comedy
Club come see me and Ralph doing
Hollywood Babylon Ralph Garman one of
the funniest [__] people I know
um and I sit next to him and laugh the
whole [__] time and stuff uh this
will only be the second Hollywood
Babylon I've ever done without being
[__] completely baked out of my mind
as of tomorrow mark it'll Mark 11 weeks
Weed Free oh that's that's almost what
two and a half months
something like that who needs math when
you got super chat and [__] like that
who needs weed when you got super chat I
might not have been stoned for the last
15 years had I known about [__] Super
Chat because that's worth [__]
dancing for man never mind I appreciate
how Alex deardoff spent 1.99 in Super
Chat to say please turn Super Chat off
Alex you're gonna have to pay a lot more
than 1.99 to get turned this [__] off oh
my God Sixto Reynoso hit the hundred
dollar Mark just to say please call out
two friends and the movies with two
friends in the movies with Matt and
Sixto where all podcasts are found
accepts podcasts proud sponsor of fat
man beyond accepts podcast
um proud sponsor of fat man beyond so
there it is kids two friends and the
movies with Matt and Sixto 100 [__]
dollars did you know that you could buy
Silent Bob this cheaply that's they
shouldn't be able to
yeah I'm happy to advertise their show
are you kidding me this is [__] this
super chat's gonna change my life this
will be the moment where everybody's
like you know where he went off the deep
end where he realized he could [__]
beg for money on YouTube my favorite
part is half of the chat coming in now
just saying what fresh hell have I
stepped into
um yes I'm coming I saw it coming 45
minutes ago this is the beginning of the
end my friend if this is the end then
I'm happy to [__] end it this way
getting 100 from 60 right no so to say
two friends in the movies with Matt and
six though man that's [__] that's
genius
um kids I know you're asking yourselves
well wait Hollywood Babylon is happening
at Flappers comedy club uh this Saturday
tickets at ceasemod.com come join us and
[__] uh when can I see you and Mark
doing fat man beyond well
we uh are gonna be doing fat man Beyond
in Los Angeles of course at scum and
villainy uh as soon as JC gets back and
we figure out our dates but
I'm gonna give you a long [__] term
date wave down the [__] Pike as they
say when me and Mark are returning to
smog Castle to do the next fat man
beyond from smog Castle which is when
Mark I believe it is August 25th if I
remember I think you're right I'm gonna
look at my schedule right here this
modcastle keeper Ernie O'Donnell is
chime in and tell me not to talk about
some other [__] uh August 25th 7 P.M fat
man return Batman Beyond returns to
smodcast castle at uh smart Castle
Cinemas in Atlantic Highlands New Jersey
and [__] for the second episode that
we'll ever record live there we had a
[__] blast it was one of my favorite
shows we ever [__] did doing it was
fun castle so now the bar is set very
[__] high I believe tickets are on
sale right now at smodcastlecinemas.com
if you want to get a jump on everybody
else and we may or may not be doing we
talked about in the last episode that we
did
we were joking around it was a [__]
punter where it happened during
The Ides of March during one of the
screenings yeah we were talking about
um Legend I think
for like half an hour and the Majesty of
Tim Curry and then then I pitched you
because apparently the way to get
yourself a screening series at smart
Castle Cinemas is to have the good pun
so the Ides of Mark was a good enough
pun
um to get three days to do that and then
I pitched keep calm and Curry on
keep keep calm and carry on is a
proposed uh
um Tim Curry appreciation Festival yeah
double feature I think
which we're not allowed to talk about
because Ernie said hey man don't talk
about that yet because first we have to
score the movie with the actual uh
exhibit or Distributors and stuff so but
if you're gonna come see us on August
25th for fat man beyond leave August 26
open not saying why but
could be that that's where we're all
going to keep calm and and Curry on man
[__] smart Castle kids
so much coming to smodcast Castle
um May I just give you I know this show
seems like one big commercial now but
can I tell you what's coming to smodcast
Castle
I'm gonna be back there on four well
number one Mission Hill is coming to do
a show on April 14th man like uh the the
member of Mission Hill the TV show
finished some episodes and they tore
them around the country so they're
coming this modcastle to do that if you
love Mission Hill come see them do the
live show uh They show cartoons then
they talk about it afterwards and stuff
um as for me and mine 420 the high
holiday if you will you want to spend it
with a guy who doesn't smoke weed come
to my castle Cinemas we're going to show
Jane Sal and Bob reboot watch Jane
Silent Bob reboot with me and mubi the
golden calf we're taking pictures and
[__] like that as well that's on 420. on
421 which is a Friday we're doing this
thing I'm very excited about uh called
Trailer Park which is uh come watch 90
minutes of trailers from the 70s 80s and
90s with with me we just sit there and
watch movie trailers oftentimes the best
part of any movie going experience I
believe we all agree these are classic
trailers from back in the day man uh
Stephen are are a digital guru at smog
Castle uh it kind of stemmed from when
we did The Ides of Mark he was putting
up trailers for cool ass [__] old
movies and I was like we should do this
for like 90 minutes straight he's like
we can so that's happening on 421 uh on
422 of course sold out you can't get
tickets we're doing Chasing Amy with
Jason Lee going to be back in town
but like I said that's all sold out but
get this [__] man on May 5th on May 5th
May the 4th of course is Star Wars Day
May 5th is Revenge of the of the fifth
but we're doing a show called revenge of
the Smith
because my name is Smith and so
basically you know in all my movies I've
always done [__] Star Wars oriented
material well we're gonna sit there I'm
going to show you every [__] Star
Wars scene from a movie I've ever made
and then I'm gonna pause it and [__]
tell you the story of how it happened
and why it happened and [__] revenge of
the Smith is happening at smog Castle
Cinemas on May 5th and then on May 6
come watch Jane Silent Bob Strike Back
with me and Jason Muse Jason Muse coming
to Smart Castle man to show [__] uh
Jane sound Bob Strike Back Then on May
7th we're going to show drawn flies
which is a movie my friend Malcolm
Ingram made in 1995 this is kind of
spiritual sequel at Mall Rats because a
lot of our casts they went up to
Vancouver and shot this movie about
looking for bigfoot uh Jason Lee gives
an amazing performance of this movie
that was so good it made me rewrite the
part of Banky and Chasing Amy because I
was like this guy could do a lot more
than [__] what I give him credit for
doing Brody and [__] like that Jason
Muse is in that Renee Humphries is in it
I pop up in it and stuff Scott moser's
in it wearing a [__] diaper Ethan
Supply pops up and I'm telling you it's
like Mallrats too for [__] sake
um is it black and white Canadian
classic ladies and gentlemen that's
happening on May 5th 7th director
Malcolm Ingram gonna be in the house JMU
is going to be in the house I will of
course always be in the house tickets at
smodcastcastlecinemas.com and the last
thing I'll promote for the time being
but please go to smartcastlecinemas.com
website and see all the [__] we got
coming including on [__] well I'll tell
you about this first we're doing a uh
the Jersey Girl the Snyder cut ladies
and gentlemen which on the internet has
become shorthand for an uncut version of
the movie the longest version of Jersey
girl that you never saw including so
much JLo that you could shake a stick at
all the J-Lo that got cut out of the
movie during its theatrical run is going
to be playing during the Jersey Girl the
Snyder cut that is on uh May 28th
um but but you know flash is coming
The Flash uh of course June 16th so the
weekend of June 16th June 17 June 18th
I'm going to be at every nighttime
showing of The Flash just watch The
Flash with me man and hopefully we're
gonna show Batman Returns that week
we'll see if Warner Brothers lets us
um I can't wait but I'm going to see
flash early man because uh was April
24th 25th 26th 27th is Cinema con used
to be called show west now it's Cinema
con which is like Comic-Con for people
that own movie theaters and [__]
um exhibitors if you will and they're
showing [__] The Flash
like two months before it comes out and
[__] and I don't know if they're gonna
make me sign an NDA but like I'm
watching the [__] out of them so I'll be
back to be like it is everything that
Tom Cruise says what did you see that
news story where like Tom Cruise saw the
Flash and he was like it's great I love
it I love it
um so I can't wait to go to cinemacon
see the [__] flesh that's why I
bought a badge just to go see the
[__] Flash and stuff and there's
other movies they're debuting and stuff
but I'm there to see the [__] that's
the flash any event bunch of [__] happen
if you want to see me on the west coast
Hollywood Babble on this weekend this
Saturday if you want to see me on the
East Coast tons of [__] shows at
smodcast Castle Cinemas go to
smartcastlecinemas.com or csmod.com
for tickets thank you for pointing all
that out
uh
dilf man our producer
I I like literally would have forgotten
because I'm so enamored of Super Chat
cannot believe that people are given
money just to say a thing how lovely
um but however and Kevin their comments
will be there later you can click the
little dollar sign at the top of the
chat we can come back to them later they
don't worry about it just is that right
yes
this [__] knows everything give
it up for [__] dilf man it keeps
popping off the screen and [__] but he
used to be down there
um all right
enough about all that shall we dive into
the meat of the show let's do it let's
let's do a quick uh round robin of the
ship that you and I have seen either
together or apart
um
you've talked about Mandalorian the most
recent episode of it the one with Jack
Black and lizzo as space paramours that
seems like the episode that everyone
online is like that's where jump the
[__] shark that's their Super Chat
episode I guess
a lot of people unhappy with the
appearance of Jack Black and lizzo a lot
of people specifically mad that lizzo
knighted grogu
in one of the moments you know I I
didn't bump into that I was like
whatever if that's what you want to do
with guest stars and [__] like that
that's totally cool I mean Christopher
Lloyd was on the [__] show all right
Chris for Lloyd but who don't love Jack
Black especially this week [__] Super
Mario Brothers like made every dollar in
the world and he's got that peaches
video like on [__] YouTube and [__]
like that yeah that's blown up but he's
eligible for an Oscar
is it really written for the movie
um but yet my man all he does is shows
up on Mandalorian and everybody's like
uh I I didn't bump into it at all I
don't give a [__] like having a Star
Wars TV show you'll never hear a
complaint out of me and [__] especially
now that we've heard from but Dave
filoni it's celebration they're gonna
wrap all that shut up in a [__] movie
yeah don't don't jump the news don't
worry about that later flew over to you
what did you think
um I I am mystified by this season of
the Mandalorian
um because it I don't I don't really
know what story it's telling anymore
other than maybe we're going to retake
Mandalore eventually kind of but then
again benjarin doesn't really give a
[__] about that part of the lore like he
just kind of wants to hang out with
grogu as does I feel like most of the
world
um and so every episode does not seem to
be about him or nor does it seem to be
about grogu now we're in the Boca tan
show which I love Katie Sackhoff she's
wonderful
um I like the character of Boca tan I'm
not as uh welded to her as some people
are because I wasn't a Clone Wars kid so
all of this sort of Mandalore lore
is a little bit like okay it's a flavor
I guess but suddenly it's become the
entire meal that we're eating
um and yes the Mandalorian can refer to
lots of different people apparently but
that's what I read in a story this week
online like uh because it said like you
know Pedro Pascal is no longer the
[__] Mandalorian and I thought it was
a story about how somebody else plays
him and he just does the voice but it's
literally like somebody with the show
not [__] favro or felony or whatever
Summit I think
the guy one of the directors Rick for me
maybe I'm not sure but somebody [__]
said that hey man what does the
Mandalorian mean it don't have to mean
him could be bo Katan could be [__]
groguing [__] they've what we all
thought the Mandalorian title referred
to to Jin Jin Jaren
Mando can now be
broader about something else or whatever
I don't know I passed a billboard every
[__] day here in town where it's
clearly [__] didn't it's clearly the
Mandalorian [__] flying around GoGo
in his arms so I you know even though
some of the stories this year have
deviated like that one would Dr Pershing
and stuff which had almost no Mando just
in the beginning and just at the tail
end
um I don't bump into that I'm like look
man I don't mind they go on Flights of
Fancy and stuff uh however we only have
one or two episodes left for this season
I think it's only eight eight episodes
this season yeah you know and so to
spend
again I just don't know the story
they're telling because they all right
we're going to spend an episode rescuing
this [__] kidnapped Mandalorian kid
from weird space vultures okay sure I
guess we can do that I don't know what
that has to do with the the main story
but maybe there is no main story maybe
we're just going back to episode of the
week it's just gonna be this and now
it's going to be like you know Law and
Order
Coruscant or whatever where we've got to
find you know it's not Coruscant I know
but we've got to find out like who's
poisoning the droids and making them
angry and then we're just it's a
detective show it's you know it's
[__] Matlock with a couple of
mandalorians and masks asking to walk in
space Matlock in space and it's like but
I don't because I don't know what then
John wants anymore and because I don't
really know what grogu wants anymore I
don't know how any of these episodes are
continuing that story I know what Boca
10 wants very much
um and so maybe it is just becoming her
show and the same with the book of Boba
Fett became Mandalorian show became
denjarin Show excellent point that's
true we thought we were watching the
Boba Fett show and then suddenly it was
the Mandalorian and Ahsoka show yeah
yeah
um
Stanley and chat who paid nothing to say
this this made me smile made me laugh he
goes please hate on Star Wars and Marvel
they deserve it no they didn't they
don't no they don't remember when there
was a world where this [__] didn't exist
and we all dreamed of like why don't
they do this [__] as a TV show now they
are I can't hate on it man
um even if even if like [__] Jack
Black's got a bushy beard and playing a
big character I I was happy for him I
was like look he's in Star Wars too uh
like I did the Jack Black lizzo thing
didn't bother me you know just because
the entire episode was bothersome to me
they didn't stand out as like oh it's
their fault like no it's actually I
don't know what we're doing anymore
you know like dinjarin makes this big
thing where he explains how it's like
well she uh I lost the dark saber
because this creature attacked me and
then she killed a creature so by right
she belongs she should have the dark
saber cool you could have told her that
at any moment over the last four
episodes but you didn't until it was
dramatic
like really okay she could have just had
it and you can't even use it you were
just being a queen about it
yes Queen uh Stanley didn't pay anything
for super chat but he's getting his
money because Mark is hating on Star
Wars
for you everybody uh Jazz PDX who also
did not [__] pay anything to ask this
question said are Fabs and felony
getting creative interference or is it
all them I saw an article where John
Favreau was like nobody's telling me
what to do this is just what I want to
do I I didn't read like creative
interference to me it doesn't read like
[__] Disney being like you should do
this or you should do this I think a
guy's got his own [__] TV show you
can do anything he wants with it and
[__] and I'm sure he meets famous people
all the time who are like oh I love that
[__] show and you know he's started
popping them in to the show like I I
don't know it didn't read like this is
all [__] Disney doing it Disney's
ruining Star Wars
I I think they could use some creative
interference
like I I think that that the show is
suffering a little bit because there's
nobody but these two guys making Star
Wars and when it works it's great but
like there's a reason why we do have
writer rooms there's a reason why that
collective experience is a net good
thing in television I mean if Tony
Gilroy can have a writer's room for
Andor then there's no reason why and
invite other people in and collaborate
and together make a great thing
I think I think Mando is suffering a
little bit from some tunnel vision
um but hey that's just me on the outside
looking in
um and and yes we are we are probably
coming to the end of the Mando cycle as
you intimated
um but I just I remember when it was a
show about a bounty hunter who found a
kid and there were no Jedis and there
was no lore and it was just a thing that
everybody could kind of jump onto and
then by now the Midway through the third
season it has become this somewhat
Byzantine exploration of the nooks and
crannies of the Star Wars universe that
if you haven't done the reading is a
little bit
I don't know
opaque uh look oh my God [__] I was just
gonna give you props for Byzantine which
I always say Byzantine like [__] you
then you then [__] close you stick
The Landing with opaque
words oh my God Mark it's the [__]
vocabulary of the day award for both
nobody gonna say anything is smart in
this show as Mark just expressed it
whether you agree with the sentiment or
not Byzantine and [__] opaque are
just like billion dollar words to just
casually drop in conversation man take
that if you're gonna take anything from
the show number one take that we jump
the shark with Super Chat
take that take Byzantine [__] opaque
into your daily conversations kids
that's what you get when you watch a fat
man beyond show you get the smarts you
get the smarts
um Picard season three is phenomenal the
card season three is I think everything
that everybody who was ever a fan of the
Next Generation always wanted Picard to
be and I say that as a person who worked
on season two
um I think that that you know this is
this is the version of the show that
that uh the shareholder Terry always
wanted to do that every writer has
always wanted that every actor who's
ever been on on Next Generation wanted
to come back and play it this is the way
to close out
storyline
um it's it's just it's it's great it is
kind of unreservedly great
um except for one reservation which is
the jack Crusher stuff I could kind of
give or take
um
but is this the last season yes the
final season so do you think so then is
that why it's great and everything that
everyone ever wanted it to be because
they're like well this is it the last
hurray it does have the feeling of like
just you know there's no reason to leave
anything behind there's no reason to
leave any ammunition in the in the in
the in the guns just blow all the
barrels like do all the things leave it
all in the field and
and it is it is Nostalgia for sure
um but it's nostalgic it gets to be
surprising in ways as Nostalgia that
gets to be
um warming in ways and emotional in ways
but it's also proper Star Trek there's
also like [__] phaser battles and and
spaceship combat and Amanda Plummer as
this wonderful villain
um it's just anybody honey bunny is
continuing her villainous ways and
taking them to outer space in the
game
um but yeah man I I completely take it I
completely dig it
um let's see John Wick four which both
of us have seen
um independent of one another
John Wick 4 is essentially four or five
of the most incredible 25 minute action
sequences anyone has ever tried to
commit to film
um we did I watched it at smog Castle
Cinemas and we did a watch Wick with Kev
so I was just in town and it was a
Saturday night I was going to watch John
Wick so I was like come watch it with me
we'll do q a afterwards and stuff I'll
do q a for a movie I had nothing to do
with and my God like at first when I sat
down in my seat like her smodcast to
keep Ernie O'Donnell is like I hope you
got two hours and 40 minutes and I was
like wise like that's how long this
movie is I was like what like you're
talking about [__] who made
clerks three it was like 94 minutes and
[__] I cut my [__] to the Bone and
whatnot and I was like I ain't got time
for [__] two hours and 30 40 minutes
whatever the [__] it was [__] went by
like that
[__] [__] flew by even at that length
man it was incredible
um
I you know I we had a discussion
afterwards about like is what's the
influence here is it [__] one long
cartoon or is it video games or what the
[__] and I was like what it is
is you could do some [__] with special
effects now that you never could before
somebody said like it's a mixture of
[__] um you know the Shaw Brothers
and and and Looney Tunes to some degree
um all it was was [__] magic I read a
story where Keanu went through and
[__] crossed out a lot of the
dialogue so it only has about 300 words
that he says in the whole movie but
there's a guy who knows his character
knows what the audience wants and [__]
it was not wanting for [__] dialogue
breathless in terms of like the action
sequences there's one like Touch of Evil
shot in that [__] just went on
and on and on like the overhead shot
dragon's breath shotgun just sparking
[__] into fire and [__] like
this I'm sorry but the the [__]
Sacred Heart
sequence the stairs sequence was just
[__] brilliant man because when he
gets to the spoilers kids it's been out
for a red hot minute but this don't
spoil the movie if you ain't seen it it
should make you want to see it
[__] there's this uh
uh the church in in France that ain't
the one that went on fire it's not Notre
Dame but it's the other one and it's all
they're big [__] selling point it's
like these stairs will give you a
[__] heart attack because there's so
many stairs to get up to the church and
[__] they do an entire action sequence
on these [__] stairs and just when
[__] Wick makes it to the top of the
[__] stairs somebody kicks them all
the way down the stairs he has to do it
again it was [__] brilliant that
moment alone I was like
because I was like yeah he's at the top
of the stairs let's go and they're like
oh no
they really know what they're doing with
this [__] series man it's absolutely
[__] phenomenal uh and the audience
that I was with ate it up like candy
wasn't a single person at the end of it
you know I go like how many people liked
it all the hands went up I was like how
many people didn't like it no [__]
hands went up
um it's just astounding to watch and
it's weird that like I can't even
consider myself
as a filmmaker when I watch a film like
this because I'm like holy [__] now you
know I understand that a lot of digital
help and [__] like is [__]
directed by a guy a stunt man right the
guy
yeah oh my God this guy's [__] so
talented this kid give him all the money
and make every [__] move give him
every one of the franchises give him a
Star Wars give him a Marvel let this guy
do whatever he [__] wants because my
God this movie was vastly entertaining
here's the highest compliment I could
pay it as I sat there watching it I
wished my [__] father who's been dead
for 20 years in June could be exhumed
from the [__] ground with a
Necronomicon just so I can show him this
movie my father was an action movie
[__] freak if he'd seen this [__]
movie he might be alive today this movie
would have kept him alive if he knew
this movie was coming one day it is it's
it's just so [__] good did you like
it
um I think every one of those action
scenes is maybe the best action scene
I've ever seen right like [__] hands
down bro I was thinking like how many
other movies in action over the years
and [__] but I'm like oh my God this is
breathtaking yeah but I will also say
you could probably cut half of those
action scenes and I would have enjoyed
the movie just as much fair enough it
did not have to be as long as it was and
like there's there's very little
suspense or pluck or character being
conveyed in any of those scenes right
like it's
here I am in this hotel in Japan which
is super cool and it's filled with
[__] assassins and I'm gonna kill
them all and make my way out right right
do we learn anything new about John Wick
no you learn anything new about the plot
no it's just can he make it out alive
and of course you can because he's John
Wick and so it becomes
it becomes a little numbing after a
while when you're just like all right so
we did a cool overhead action scene and
then we're in the The Arc of Triumph car
chase scene where people jumping out and
get killed and it's amazing and then
we're doing a staircase scene and that's
40 minutes of just things exploding and
cars screeching and guns firing which
is a lot if there's no emotional tether
to any of it you know is there did you
not have an emotional tender this is a
this is a this all began mind you with a
guy really upset that they killed a
[__] puppy and I love the first movie
The First movie is perfect but it
doesn't have it doesn't have what this
movie had like it feels like
they started in a very realistic kind of
world with the first one and I've not
watched The Fast and Furious movies but
like you have oh yes your description of
them was like
because I remember the first one and I
was like it's just about car racing and
you're like oh it's gone beyond that bro
they go to space yeah
and it feels like they've upped the ante
every [__] go around
um but I I'm here for it man like I
loved what they did in [__] chapter
four John Wick chapter four yeah but
remember the very simple premise of John
Wick like this is a man who's pissed off
that they killed this [__] dog and
his wife but dog first and [__] yeah but
it was it was the like my wife died and
the last gift she gave to me was this
dog to help me grieve so I wouldn't have
to grieve her death alone and you killed
that symbol of of Salvation that I had
so I'm going to lay ways to everybody to
get my [__] revenge and he does okay
I get it that's pure it's simple by this
movie it seems as if it's going to be
about John Wick the only way he can get
out and live a life is to get rid of the
high table completely right I gotta kill
of last [__] dude to kill and you're
like oh all right cool it's gonna be
this Marquee guy right who's super fun
like yeah all of his suits are amazing
the amount of like just Venom that oozes
from from that dude one of the Skarsgard
Stars guard boys
he's great but then somebody says oh
well if you just kill him they'll
replace him with somebody else but let's
all do this says Winston The Amazing Ian
McShane so I can get my hotel back
and so John Wick dies asterisk so that
another dude can get his hotel back
he doesn't get rid of the high table he
doesn't get revenge for his wife like
all of it is kind of just like a real
estate transaction
and at the end of all that I kind of
wanted it to mean more
and it really doesn't you know it's just
it's a little bit futile and if that's
the point they wanted to make okay
that's a choice that like all of that
death ultimately doesn't amount to
anything that there is no there is no
getting rid of this system
the best you can do is try to live your
life in a way that you can find some
honor in I get it but it's also a little
like for this movie in which this dude
is a superhero like it's going to be an
oddly Hollow ending and the asterisk is
because I don't think John Wick is dead
if they decide they want to make another
movie I think I think the director was
it's Chad chance to housekeep yeah Chad
stachelski has said there's going to be
a chapter five
yeah I mean they're like maybe a
spin-off about the Donnie Yen character
who's super cool Kane he's great you
know they're definitely doing a
ballerina movie out of the whole like
Russian ballerina assassin training
school
um
and you know they're like well we'll see
if we have another idea but if you don't
see a body going into a coffin and a
coffin going into a grave then it's not
a character who has to be dead and we
saw the same [__] gravesite for for
Nick Fury like eight times and that
[__] never seems to die so he's
got I saw him in a trailer for a [__]
secret Invasion he's back like crazy
yeah yeah so like I I appreciate these
movies with what for what they do to the
craft and and Chad is a he's he's a
wizard at this and he's figured out a
way to advance the technology of stunts
and of action and a lot of that stuff is
practical I mean there's some CG stuff
for sure but like keanu's doing like 90
of that stuff yes I mean it's [__] at
one point dude he's working nunchucks
where you're like
how's this guy have time to be a
nunchucks expert like he's in [__] so
many movies and [__] and he's older than
me and you right he's got like 55 56
years old yeah he's almost [__]
working the Chucks like [__] nobody's
business it was so awesome that when he
stopped working the Chucks he just let
him hang around his neck and then
[__] picked him back up and [__]
one we had a good time after the movie
during the Q a talking about I had um
Shane uh who's my A.D on clerks three
Shane Kalman
um was there watching with me so I was
like you get up and do q a with me and
[__] because I was like Shane how long
does it take to do something like the
art the Triumph scene and [__] and we
were trying to break down for the
audience how much of it was real and how
much of it was [__] done elsewhere
and stuff you know because we had
definitely had some people in the
audience who thought like all that
traffic was really there and I'm like oh
no
so much of that comes together in post
and whatnot but do you think he was
actually working nunchucks or do you
think he's doing this [__] and they put
nunchucks in his hand later on I think
he's working them I mean that's what I
thought I was like meaning that he does
I mean Chad Chad did a lot of press I
mean there's been a ton of pressure on
each one of these movies but he said
like I bring the stunt team in
you know four to six months before we
start shooting and Keanu is training for
six to eight months before we start
shooting so that he can do as much of it
as possible
and like all of the martial arts stuff
and stuff he's doing like he's not
there's there's always the line between
like are we gonna kill Keanu or are we
just going to ding Keanu and it's like
he's taking a lot of those hits we're
not slamming him into Vans at 100 miles
an hour like that's either a stunt guy
or CG but like Keanu wants to do it all
Keanu like every time the gun jams that
they use it's because the gun really
jammed and Keanu just knows what to do
and he knows how to play it as part of a
scene he knows what John Wick would do
with Jan Dunn
and I also Mike to your point we talked
about this years ago years ago months
ago I don't know time there are no live
rounds on the sets of those movies it's
like every gun is a non-fire of a Gun
there's no muzzle flash on the set like
everything is digital all of it it's
like I just won't there's no reason to
do it as and we have not done it on any
of these movies like we can we can fake
the the slide going back and forth we
can eject empty shells onto the ground
if we have to but you could not put a
bullet in any gun that's on any one of
these sets and fire it
which you have to give credit to the
performers because they make it look
like just enough recoil and [__] like
that like he's not just going like this
and His Hands not really moving it looks
like they're firing [__] guns and I
don't mean visually it looks like it
with the puzzle flash that they add
later on and stuff but to be an actor in
the middle of a [__] scene where
you're beating up a hundred [__]
people and you still have an in a uncut
[__] shot that goes on for minutes
and you still have the presence of mind
to still [__] jerk just enough to
have you [__] be like yeah he's
firing a [__] gun right there they
don't even have to then we have to fake
it because they've built it with like
Motors inside of it that that shimmy it
just enough so when you press the
trigger the motor starts spinning and it
gives you that feel so you can see like
flesh jiggle when the gun is moving yeah
right yeah yeah like and I think they
had it God when do they have four
remember WETA had worked on something
like that like 10 or 15 years ago
because they also realized back then
maybe we don't need bullets anymore we
don't need blanks anymore
um but no I I think that the discreetly
like every 10 minutes of that movie is a
masterpiece I just think that when you
put it all together to two hours and 40
minutes worth of it it uh the the the
parts I think are a little bit more than
the whole
but that is just me
um
Joshua mondal who was one of our [__]
super Chatters asked a free question
Kevin Mark Berserker keanu's comic have
you read any of it yet what do you think
of an upcoming upcoming animated series
slash movie have you ever read his comic
I have not read his comic um I know
others are doing it they are doing a
cartoon right I think Netflix got the
rights and I think they have a whole
like Suite of things they want to do
with it I think they want to do a live
action thing I don't think they want to
do an animated thing
I think that you know the Keanu of it
gets you quite a bit of of avenues of
exploitation for that and it seems fun
it seems fun it's a boom comic and the
guys of Boom are super smart can I tell
you an inside [__] baseball story
that I think has something to do with
that shoot so uh years ago I was working
on a live-action Buckaroo Banzai TV
series at first we sold it to Apple MGM
owns it at first we I got involved with
the good Folks at MGM because like we
hear you love buckaroo banza I was like
[__] yeah I love Bakugan so we pitched
it to Apple got bought like in a
heartbeat and [__] was it apple or
Amazon Amazon first I think I don't know
one of them either Apple bought it first
then Amazon bought it after or Amazon
bought it first and apple bought it
after ironically enough it was the same
guy both companies who bought it his
name was Morgan he was to do the bought
it so we were doing a live action
version of the show
um and they the whoever we wound up with
ultimately I think it was Apple
remember who went first they both begin
with a
um so whoever was whether it was Apple
or whether it was Amazon it'd be
somebody in chat [__] remembers
um
they those cats were like I don't know
maybe it's not a live action series
maybe it's an animated series and so I
got some cool ass designs from the folks
of Powerhouse animation
um guys who I do uh and girls with uh uh
Masters of the Universe with for Netflix
in any event
they designed this
um someone says gravitated said would
someone please get Kevin hi why like I
was more obnoxious when I was I I was
way more last time yeah truly
um so
uh cool ass designs very manga very
anime influence for Buckaroo Banzai
animated series and I I cannot tell you
how this happened
but
somebody was like you know who's
interested in playing Buckaroo Banzai in
your animated series
Keanu Reeves I was like what the [__] so
they hooked up Zoom with with me and and
Keanu and I'd met him once before also
on Zoom uh for the Bill and Ted uh face
the music like uh Premiere or whatever
they put together this like online
[__] panel and stuff during the days
of covet and you know I was like oh my
God I had to tell him like look [__]
we don't get to Silent Bob we don't get
to Jay and Silent Bob without Bill and
Ted and we don't get to sound bar
without Theodore uh Ted Theodore Logan
and chip
um and he was like whoa and so here we
are [__] a year or two after that and
we're doing another Zoom but this time
it's not in front of the world and [__]
it's just literally
me and [__] Keanu
and he goes
so Buckaroo Bonsai and I was like yeah
man and and we talked for like half an
hour and this is this is a like it's
it's never happened in a [__] but this
is it ties into that Berserker thing
by the end of the conversation he was
like let's do this man and I was like oh
my God this Show's actually gonna
[__] happen and then one week later
he sent me a lovely email where he was
like I have to back out of the show he's
gone I hope we get to work together one
day polite as [__] he's a Canadian kid
so he's just absolutely [__]
wonderful and [__] I think
it probably had to do with Berserker
because I think he's like oh if I'm
gonna do a cartoon I'm gonna do cartoon
based on my comic book lovely lovely
[__] dude but for one brief Shining
Moment for about a week or two week
period we could have had Buckaroo Banzai
played by Keanu Reeves in an animated
series oh that would have been amazing
um Peter Weller for the record if anyone
was like what about [__] Peter Weller
he would have played Hanoi Shan uh who
is if you know the Buckaroo Bonsai world
and the book written by Earl the great
Earl McGraw
um that's his Lex Luthor
um that doesn't really get much play in
the Buckaroo Banzai movie
um but him in the book him and Lizardo
are like this and [__] now I'm falling
down the rabbit hole and whatnot but
there you go anyway yes so uh John Wick
4 made all the money it's you know if
they want to make a fifth they can
they're spaying it out a dozen different
ways
um including a continental Continental
TV series right which I worked on
um
that's right you did I did
um I'm pretty sure that if I remember
correctly the Continental is now three
TV movies
and not a TV series
um but it was all about the uh the how
Winston gets the hotel it was a it would
be young Winston like not Winston you
know young Sharon
um there were a couple of other
characters from the WIC universe that we
were sort of beginning to bring in but
uh and we'd always had this idea of like
young [__] John Wick
um or jordani whatever his Russian name
is jovanovic
um but I don't think we ever landed on a
really interesting way to bring him in
to have made it worth it but like season
two or three will totally bring in young
John Wick
um but uh but yeah no and you know I got
to work a little bit with Chad in like
picking his brain about how that world
works and he's a very intense but very
nice guy but he's always on he's always
kind of moving
um never got to be Buchanan who I think
is is both nice but a little bit of the
opposite
you know like Chad was intense but uh
but yeah he was very he was very cool
but in text while we're talking about
Wick we should give a shout out pour one
out for Lance Reddick indeed indeed this
is the just as the movie opened uh the
concierge himself
um passed away like rather suddenly and
also very young I think we talked did we
talk about it on the yeah in the last
part yeah like that was the breaking
news that day was like you know that's
right rmp
um two quick trailers to hit before we
dig into Star Wars celebration stuff
there was a new across the spider verse
trailer that dropped
man alive just give it all to me yeah
for one like they may they bring in the
spot was very fun
um it looks like a you know they get a
lot of jokes out of that character and
[__]
um but [__] who knew
that uh [__] Spider-Man 2099
was gonna like play such a massive
massive [__] part yeah and played by
what's as [__] Oscar Isaac Oscar Eisen
great Oscar eyes Moon Knight himself
who's like gets to be two [__] Marvel
characters in this world three if you
count [__] apocalypse
indeed so yeah cannot wait for that
that's I think June I said June yeah I
think it's June that looks amazing
uh and also the bringing in [__]
Peter Peter Parker comes back with
[__] spider baby I know
um so I guess [__] worked out with him
and Mary Jane that's like I love that
movie so much across the the original uh
into the spider-verse yeah
um and that trailer just has the line
where you know his mother is is talking
to him on the roof and it's just like
you know you were a little boy and I
just don't want you to forget the the
boy that that we helped raise the boy
that we love and I want you to protect
him and make sure that he's okay and
just like all of the feelings are all
bubbling in my body and I don't know
what to do about it it's beautiful
beautiful [__] yeah
um and then the Blue Beetle trailer
dropped our first wonderful
I thought it was really strong man I was
I honestly like Ted court is my Blue
Beetle and I was never like uh I was out
of comics by the time I may came around
I'm well aware of the character and
whatnot but you know I grew up reading
Justice League International [__] all
the Blue Beetle [__] Booster Gold
[__] by uh damatus and Giffin and stuff
so Ted cord is was and will always be my
Blue Beetle
um that being said holy [__] man like
they've made a [__] really good
looking movie I hope that this isn't one
of these Shazam Fury the gods things
where they're like well
the same part of the James Gunn plan I
hope going forward
they keep this up well I hope the
movie's as good as the trailer did you
like the trailer I dug the trailer I
mean I think it's [__] man yeah I think
the the cutest playing Jaime Reyes is
super Charming that's the kid from
[__] Cobra Kai right yeah yeah I
don't know what his last name God he was
so uh he was the heart of Cobra Kai man
at least season one and season two I
remember when he [__] like spoilers
when he gets [__] knocked off the
railing and [__] I was like oh like
I was very happy in season two yeah so
I'm I'm looking forward to it the the
one quibble that I have is that
superhero origin stories are at this
point not entirely interesting to me
because most of them are the same you
know it's the I found a piece of tech
that will transform my life and help
change everything from this piece of
[__] to what I wanted to be or I got
bitten or exposed or irradiated or or my
parents got killed or something bad
happened to my parents that motivates me
to do whatever or I'm an alien and look
I just found out all of that stuff like
we've seen the five or six variations on
the theme
and so
I I keep longing for either some new
version of that or to just skip right
over
like if I ever see pearls again in a
Batman movie
[__] you like I know this origin already
everybody does I don't ever need to see
Peter Parker get bitten by a spider
again we know how that works yes Kalel
came from Krypton we get it don't ever
show me that [__] again sounds like guns
not going to show you that in the movie
that he's now directing as well as
writing yeah like it seems Superman
Legacy is very much about like a
Superman who's already Superman who has
questions about what that is and I'm all
for that I mean it's we've been telling
that origin now for almost 90 years I
think we get it
um so so yeah like I'm I'm here for Blue
Beetle I'm very curious about what it is
and what it looks like and how it
operates
um and the trailer looks good it's just
that little bit of like okay no if if
this follows the beats that I know then
you know it'll be those things in the
periphery that get me excited unless the
central core of what it is but I reserve
judgment until I see the movie and I
live in Hope filth yes nerd large I'm
complaining about movies that I haven't
even watched yet and just said I live at
hope I haven't seen it yet this is
trailer
simmer did that person pay money to ask
you that question he did not native
someone wants to know if they can
negotiate the rate down to Super Chat
no Kevin I just wanted to contribute
that uh actually the Blue Beetle movie
was supposed to be an HBO Max film until
James Gunn saw it and he said no no no
we're going theatrical is that right
that's the rumor I heard I don't know
I'd always heard that it was supposed to
be theatrical and then there was a
danger that it might go he [__] says
[__] and then it [__] off I was in the
middle of a conversation get back here
Dylan right here man stand by yourself
he's here
um I hadn't heard that I I thought it
was always meant to be theatrical and
maybe during the Zas law there there was
a danger that it might go the way of
well not Batgirl and be [__] canceled
but it might just go to HBO Max but that
would be a new one I hadn't heard that
uh speaking of Super Chat though rain
serving paid 10 bucks to say this hey
Kev I want to thank you for sharing your
heart attack story on the podcast years
ago without it my dad wouldn't be here
today so I'll always be in your dead
number one thank you number two you're
in the debt of the doctors who saved
your Dad's life
um I'm glad I said a thing and you maybe
heard a thing and when the time was
right said a thing to your
[__] dad and I'm glad your dad's
alive and stuff
um but for years people ever since our
zag and [__] I've been talking about
it I've met heard from people online met
him in the real world people giving me
credit for saving their lives saving the
life of a loved one because I talked
about this heart attack [__]
um I I did not I just passed on some
good information [__] I didn't know and
so that's you know been my
Mo for the last few years is like oh
[__] I didn't know this [__] so when I
started telling the story about my heart
attack it was really passed out
information like you know I always
thought [__] your arms got to go numb
or Elizabeth you got to do a red fox in
order to know you're having a heart
attack but like being nauseous
having the sweats these are all [__]
warning signs as well so I thank you for
that rain uh but you saved your Dad's
life and more importantly the doctors
saved your Dad's life but I'm so glad
your dad's around take them for when we
we're just talking about Mark not
wanting to see another superhero origin
and stuff and we talked about my parents
are dead like you know that was me
making jokes about Comics but instantly
with flash to my head is my dad is dead
and that should have been my superhero
origin
story moment but it's not
it's coming up in June it'll be dead 20
[__] years like I said before when I
was talking about [__] John Wick I
think about him when I see these [__]
movies now because I'm like oh my God
like that's what he loved when I showed
him Chasing Amy for the first time he
fell asleep because that wasn't his
[__] speed and [__] I didn't have
Clint Eastwood in it didn't have a
[__] single gun or anything like that
but man oh man if he had lived to see
Wick [__] my old man would be let me see
he died at six seven so he'd be 87 now
um
so I don't know if he would have made it
regardless of his poor health and
whatnot but I wish he had I guarantee
you if I could [__] sink
John Wick 4 into the bowels of the earth
it would raise my father's corpse if he
weren't you know
cremated because I got a piece of him
and a nurn right over there
my mom put him into this urn God bless
her
I remember when my father died she's
like I bought your father the most
beautiful urn and she showed it to me
and it was like this this
bronze Affair of like waves and it had
three Dolphins cresting over it and
she's like that's meant to be you and
your brother and your sister and me and
and dad are the waves and whatnot and
you know I was like my poor father is
going to spend the rest of his life in
the in this Ethan Allen [__]
sculpture like oh my God my mom said do
you want some of your dad's ashes I said
[__] yeah I got him a nice respectable
very simple wouldn't urn that I took
with me to when I got my hand and
Footprints put in the semantic growman's
Chinese Theater so that my dad could be
there too and then right before I left
like it wasn't something I was planning
to do but I looked down and there was
this perfect space
in the cement it's still wet you know
where I put my handprints my footprints
written my name and wrote some [__] in
the date blah blah and then there was
this just empty spot and I looked at the
urn it was almost the same [__] size
so I took the urn and I put it down into
the cement made a perfect like circle
from the bottom of the urn and stuff so
if you ever go see like the growman's
Chinese Theater the courtyard where all
the footprints of the famous people are
the less famous Jay and Silent bobber
there me and Jason Muse right next to
each other but my father who took me to
groman's Chinese Theater when I was
[__] nine years old on a family
vacation to the courtyard and was
explaining like [__] everybody who I
didn't know in the cement some people I
didn't know I was there to see the Star
Wars Footprints like R2D2 C3PO and Darth
Vader and [__] and right before we left
my old man was like maybe you'll be here
one day and [__] like 40 years later
I was there so it was beautiful moment
for me to put his his ashes in the
[__] cement with me something that I
could not have done if it was just my
mom's gigantic [__] dolphin urn and
stuff
I shouldn't be [__] [__] talking my
mom she's in the hospital right now but
she knows how I feel about that Eric you
know what you did
sorry I'm dealing with some [__] kids
thank you rain serving for letting me
[__] tell a story about my dad anyway
should we uh should we enroll the
beautiful Bean footage of JC at the
celebration we should because it'll give
us six minutes to not
deal with super chat with a lot of
people are so irritated by
um kids uh JC Banff man himself uh the
proprietor owner and proprietor of the
scum and villainy cantina our home
for this show uh which uh even when
during a pandemic we would go to an
empty scum and villainy cantina and do
the [__] show uh if you've never been
to Hollywood
make a trip just like my old man [__]
took me when I was nine years old my
family and stuff make a trip to
Hollywood one day and make sure you go
to the scum and villainy cantina there
ain't no bar like it anywhere on the
planet and stuff
um don't call it a Star Wars bar
because now it's a Star Trek bar they
had a [__] shindig there not too long
ago for [__] uh yeah was the show
from Picard yeah and they like redid the
whole like entryway so that now it's all
like a [__] Holodeck thing or
whatever it's All Star Trek screens
everywhere dope one day JC's gonna be
the richest person we know because he's
gonna franchise this [__] and there's
gonna be [__] scum and villainy
Cantinas all over the [__] world
um but regardless JC Banff man himself
as you all know is a massive massive
[__] Star Wars fan so massive that he
went over to England where they're doing
[__] uh Star Wars celebration this
year something that at first I was like
can you believe they moved this [__] out
of America until somebody was like you
know they made Star Wars in London at a
long time ago good point they deserve it
as well so the celebration went to the
UK this year and um uh Brian Lynch our
friend Brian Lynch he went over and
stuff uh and Jason they went over as
well and so we were gonna try to do JC
coming in live
um from like at one point mark was
pitching it was it was three time zones
two countries one podcast because I was
supposed to be on the East Coast Mark
was going to be on the west coast and JC
was going to be over in [__] England
but as the case is me and Mark are right
now both in [__] California so we're
in one time zone and JC when we were
like you ready to do this [__] six
o'clock PST [__] America time on
[__] Monday and JC was like that's
three in the morning for me okay
although we got a bunch of people super
chatting this [__] pound sterling who
are obviously watching the show at
[__] 3 A.M so I don't know what JC's
problem is but JC said I'm not gonna be
there live but I will
send you a [__] video and [__] so JC
said it was gonna be a two minute video
he turned into a six minute video if I
remember correctly
um here with a special report
from Star Wars celebration get in here
dilf man
how adorable is that uh how long is that
video uh six minutes 50 seconds I
believe
six minutes and 50 seconds so we're
gonna go to Celebration with our beloved
Banff man who's not here because he's
over [__] in the UK and whatnot uh
and watch six minutes of video don't
[__] touch that dial because as soon
as it's done me and Mark are going to be
back talking all about celebration
because we made JC promise he wouldn't
spoil everything he's there his piece is
about his personal experience and
whatnot uh we'll be back to talk about
all the [__] news that came out of
Star Wars celebration including that
[__] amazing Ahsoka trailer uh which
looks like [__] Rebel season [__]
five or whatever three uh as soon as
JC's done talking so without further Ado
uh jilfman take us
to the UK man uh that'll give me a
chance to go take a whiz uh and and
let's see what JC has to say
what's up Batman Beyond I am here in
London at Star Wars celebration it just
ended it's done it's over four days like
Lightning Fast came and went uh lots of
really really cool stuff lots of fun
costumes some of my favorite uh I saw
cloud
with the full-on like Kenner action
figure costume I saw a single and mace
tawani from the Ewok Adventure movie
bumped into some fat and Beyond fans who
recognized me and talked to them which
I'll play those videos a little bit
later in my uh little breakdown here uh
huge Star Wars news announcements for
Ahsoka and the Acolyte and even Indiana
Jones because I guess that's Star Wars
adjacent a lot of really cool vendors
um other really cool stuff uh I saw here
in London which was also wild because
every time you talk to a little kid here
with the accent they're so proper you
feel like you're talking to an adult uh
that's been wild what else some really
cool scenery
um we've got an indoor bunker we've got
the Hoth turret and there's an
animatronic probe Droid that was driving
around here which was cool lots of r2d2s
uh lots of Wookies lots of mandalorians
a lot of mandalorians I also saw the
first time I've ever seen this the
wet-haired Luke Skywalker in
stormtrooper outfit with a dianoga
around his neck Volkswagen was here they
like wrapped some of their new electric
VW buses there was Star Wars gaming long
line if you wanted to demo the new Star
Wars miniature game that's coming out uh
there was an Ewok on a hang glider the
whole weekend that was really cool what
else did we see oh uh the emperor had
his chair and was doing photo ops with
people I think my personal favorite part
was
uh coming to the convention today with
Jocelyn it's just the two of us and she
walked right over to the Hasbro booth
and found the Retro remakes of the
Vintage Kenner action figures and she
sat down for 10 whole minutes just
looking at them and talking about them
and explaining who all the characters
were to me it honestly like it it was uh
kind of like what Ben Affleck says in
Jay and Silent Bob reboot is that uh
sooner or later you realize that you are
Thomas Wayne and not Bruce Wayne and
that uh that moment uh is something that
I will carry with me uh forever because
I was doing the same thing when I was
her age uh only I was at Toys R Us uh if
anybody remembers what that is all in
all a wonderful weekend with my family a
wonderful weekend with my Star Wars
family and they just announced about
five minutes ago that the next one is
going to be in Japan in two years so
start saving your shekels because we are
going to Japan in 2025. uh I will be
back
on fat and Beyond
in two or three weeks uh when I get back
from my european vacation until then
will wil Wilkins will hold it down with
Kevin and Mark
um
and maybe I'll get a better haircut by
the time I come home we'll see you guys
uh in a few weeks
I almost forgot here are interviews I
did randomly on the show floor from
London with a couple fat man beyond fans
who recognized me from the United States
all right fat man beyond here we are I
was recognized not hard with my stupid
haircut I'm with Doug from Seattle how
has this show been Doug it's been
fantastic loved every day when did you
get here we got here Thursday so we've
been here the whole weekend and are you
leaving tomorrow oh no we're gonna stay
for a few more days oh nice
up our two or R2D2 is about to run over
my daughter what was uh what's been your
favorite part of the show
what have you gotten into have you
gotten into any panels yeah we got into
the Soca panel and the Overflow for
badass how was the Ahsoka panel was he
crazy did people go nuts yeah it looks
cool did you did you read the heir to
the Empire books back in the day we're
probably around the same age did you go
nuts when Ahsoka said heard of the
empire
I didn't go nuts but I knew exactly did
you get chills a little bit did you feel
like it brought me back they they were
talking to you that they put something
in there just for you that's how I felt
yeah they knew who they were hurting
all right that's it that's what we got
with Doug I'm Gonna Keep keep searching
what up everybody back with another fat
man beyond fan this is Chris from
Philadelphia
Chris what was your favorite part of the
convention so far oh god dude leave that
with you uh just just walking around
like this one is actually one of my
favorite ones like that like I've been
four now like what even seven uh 11 11.
since you were a child I've been coming
to this wow what what
um what's the best costume you've seen
I gotta say I I gotta send you pictures
all right we'll we'll put them up we'll
put them up
what um
what has been did you get any panels did
you do any panels I did do panels I've
got uh uh uh day one I got the lucasfilm
panel and uh see seeing like uh the six
minutes of uh uh the new uh Indiana
Jones
Indiana Jones footing yeah what about
what about the Ahsoka trailer how did
that play
but
let's try it out
yeah let's effing go dude like
there it is more fat man beyond fans and
you can drink beer here
good time
is that we back
now I can point that way [__] I never
get this right God damn it
you I could go like that [__] him uh
hold on
number one just to listen to [__]
some of the chat people who absolutely
love that sequence
um somebody said that [__] where is
it
it wasn't a Super Chat
but it was
I can't find it where is it no here it
is oh Reuben KIRO said JC should cosplay
as craglin for Guardians 3 next month
gonna do
kind of did look like a man but future
uh Maya says uh Futurama yeah sorry says
he looks like the character from the
first episode of the droids cartoon he
[__] did man I wonder
um how nice what a great report that was
uh from JC uh from Batman himself
and he uh he you know edited it together
and [__] while he's over there enjoying
his ass his wheel on the Fly Just
swapping us to make people feel better
he's moving [__] around he wants to put
us back in our places
it feel like the beginning of The Brady
Bunch
the square is moving yeah it's like I I
[__] it up because I turned off my
camera when I went to the yeah when I
went to the
no it's just me I muted my camera when I
went to The Whiz Palace and then came
back oh are you muted some people are
saying you're muted
yeah I was to make sure that I couldn't
be heard while JC was talking my
favorite part of me the whole thing is
I'm apologizing to the audience because
you guys shifted around didn't know why
I went to go soup and ta-da there you
are they say you're still muted
don't worry about it it's a delay Mark
you can't believe the audience trust me
fair enough
um so celebration let's talk about
celebration before we do that I just
want to point out tickets for fat man
beyond August 25th at smog Castle are
now up as are tickets for the 826 thing
that I'm not supposed to necessarily
mention but you can still buy tickets
for it
I should also point out we're doing
Hollywood Babylon me and Ralph Garman at
Flappers Comedy Club this Saturday here
in Los Angeles but June 2nd Hollywood
Babylon traveling back to smodcast
Castle to do a show yes Ralph Garmin
coming back to New Jersey we're doing uh
Hollywood Babylon on June 2nd uh it's
not up yet but red State's going to be
on June 3rd and Ralph was in that so
he's going to be there and then we're
also doing Hollywood Babylon Comic-Con
theater on June 4th that's where me and
and Ralph read comic books and Ralph
does funny voices those tickets are now
on sale at
smodcastlecinemas.com and then it's
modcastle keeper Ernie O'Donnell asked
me to mention one more time that this
Friday kids
this Friday
at smart Castle Cinemas is a night in
Mission Hill with Bill Oakley and Josh
Weinstein man the kids responsible
for Mission Hill uh you can go see that
this [__] Friday right if you're in
on the east coast and you love Mission
Hill
here's your chance come smilecastle and
see it kids anyway back to the
Celebration and one other thing as when
we started our uh friendly neighborhood
dilfman was kind enough for mine is that
this is fat man beyond episode 398.
um slash Fat Man on Batman
um all in 398 which means we are two
episodes away from 400. Batman 400
Batman 400 which we should probably make
a bit of a big deal about we should and
we should do that where the show has
been live mostly of course which would
be at the scum and villainy cantina so
when
JC gets back which should be soon as he
said
um we'll figure out what that date is
going to be we'll put those tickets on
sale for uh at scum and villainy cantina
man we should probably do both shows
live 399 and 400 but the very least 400
has to be [__] live from the Cantina
hell yeah I wonder if we can get a
special guest
who would you get if you get anybody if
we could get anybody yeah I mean
anybody
I think I do my father because that
would mean he'd be alive again Victor
Garber Jesus Victor oh my God what a
great answer you know what my dad's dead
and he's never coming back but Victor
Garber
there's a [__] we could talk to
yeah I was I was gonna say Affleck
oh I would love to have [__] Ben
Affleck on number one we would talk
about [__] Justice League Batman v
Superman we talk about his time in the
suit number two we could talk about air
which I went to the premiere of and my
God it's [__] wonderful like it's a
legit wonderful [__] movie there's no
way they don't remember this movie when
it comes Oscar time [__] next year
he directed the [__] out of this movie
man and he's also legit wonderful as was
the dude's name Phil Knight in the movie
like look I'm a big Affleck fan
obviously and I love Affleck the
director is absolutely wonderful and
he's way better than me at the job but
Affleck the [__] actor I've always
been a fan of and seeing him play
[__] Phil Knight was delightful
Maddie Damon is [__] wonderful in the
movie everyone Pyle Davis Chris Tucker
[__] Marlon Wayans uh Chris basina
like the [__] cast is fantastic and
the movie's just such a great American
success story and [__] like that if you
were alive in the 70s and 80s like me
and Mark particularly for 1984. it's a
[__] fall down memory foals like
right down the rabbit hole of all my
most cherished memories of the 80s the
soundtrack
plays like the most expensive 80s
soundtrack ever put together every scene
has a classic song from 82 to 84 and
[__]
um it also like you know the movie that
I'm making next 4 30 movie is set in
1986. so I went to the premiere with
arley's boyfriend Austin and [__] and as
we're sitting there we're the first ones
in the [__] theater because I stopped
smoking weeds and now I'm on time for
everything almost except for this show
um as we sat there alone in the [__]
theater waiting for the rest of the
crowd to come you know at premieres
General they'd Play the soundtrack while
you're waiting for the movie to begin
and after like the fourth song I was
like oh [__] this is all going to be the
soundtrack got to be one of the most
expensive soundtracks of all time man
but like if you're it played like my
Spotify playlist every song that I still
listen to to this day and [__] uh the
movie is legit wonderful
um so happy for Ben he's a talented
[__] we all know
but my God this movie is fantastic and
I'll just say that because like I know
the guy and [__] um this movie will do
fine without me I think it opened at
like 12 million this weekend or
something like that yeah it open strong
for the kind of movie that it is
especially considering that like Super
Mario Brothers sucked up all the [__]
money from the box so this is definitely
a kids weekend at the box office this
week for those who follow along with
this sort of thing I talked about on the
last fat man beyond when we did bumps
mod Castle how [__] nobody goes to
the movies anymore uh at least mod
Castle Cinemas and [__] uh you know
opening [__] night of Avatar seven
o'clock show we had 12 people opening
night of [__] Creed Three and these
were movies that were huge we had six
people Super Mario Brothers
like apparently all right spot Gaza
Cinemas are like a rep house where you
can watch old Kevin Smith movies and
[__] cartoons kids come Galore to
that theater so Ernie texts me on
[__] Wednesday to be like we had 200
guests on a Wednesday I thought it was
cute that he called him guests I was
like what are we [__] Disneyland stop
that [__] the customers are you a cast
member too yes
oh that's good deep cut but yeah man
[__] uh Super Mario Brothers was huge
this weekend as we all probably have
heard by now and we'll continue to be
[__] huge
um but air did very [__] well
considering what it is like a grown-up
movie for grown-ups set in an era that
any you know most of us are [__]
middle-aged to appreciate but it's such
a well-made movie and honestly it's an
Amazon movie so it doesn't they ain't
got to worry about [__] box office
and [__]
um go see it kids if you haven't seen
air
[__] is worth the trip man Ben did a
great [__] job Maddie's [__]
wonderful in the movie they're all good
there's all star casts and they're all
[__] fantastic that movie had a smile
on my face from beginning to [__] end
um [__] wonderful and so smart I
haven't seen it yet but I did encounter
because you know of course both Matt and
Ben are out doing press for it and I saw
the greatest anecdote and it did warm my
heart a bit where it was the the
screenwriter was talking about his
process like it's his first ever
produced screenplay he like excellent
screenplay by the way excellent he had
the idea like a decade ago and it was
kind of like you know noodling at him
and really inspired by the Last Dance
the Michael Jordan documentary and then
kind of lit a fire in himself and wrote
it and they got in the hands of Matt you
know and Ben and like is it like when
they're on set like both Matt and better
[__] Oscar winning writers and so
like they kept on adding stuff and and
did his directors pass in the script and
they were kind of improving stuff on the
on the day and it's like the script the
screenplay had you know like seven or
eight voices in it
and then you know the screenwriter Adam
Conner I think his name is said that he
was on set like a late in production and
Ben pulled him aside and said you know
what we're gonna We're Not Gonna
arbitrate like you're gonna have soul
credit on the screenplay because this is
your idea like you're the guy who wrote
the first script like you're the guy who
pulled it out of obscurity you're the
guy you're the reason why we're all here
like yeah we all helped but you have
soul screamed like credit on this movie
that we all worked on I was like you
know what [__] it that's right like
that's that's the way you do that which
is yeah man you're the director you're
gonna get all the credit anyway you're
getting paid four times when that kid is
getting paid
you did your work you made it great and
you let him have his moment Affleck is a
classy dude he was raised right I saw
his mom at the premiere and like last
time I saw her was much heavier than I
was so I was [__] looking I went and
saw Ben and Jen and chit chatted with
them and then when I was leaving I saw
Chris app like I was like oh [__] and so
I got in her eye line because she was
having a conversation with somebody and
she looked at me and then looked away
and I was like what the [__] and then I
went over and I was like mother Affleck
it's it's Kevin Smith she goes oh my
where did you go and I was like I lost a
little weight and [__] like that
um she was very [__] sweet but
what was my point in telling that story
oh raised right and I told her that I
was like this [__] owes you
everything he was raised by an educator
and his mom's a teacher and [__] like
that so everybody's always like yeah
every once in a while a new Affleck
thing comes out and people suddenly
realize that he speaks very fluent
Spanish one of his many gifts like all
week long on the internet people are
like [__] calling him Ben call him
Benito
but uh his mom I gave him credit for
that and she was like Kevin I didn't
teach him Spanish I was like you taught
him [__] everything
credit
um somebody said
he said in who was a bonanista said is
air historically accurate Ben addressed
this when he got up to intro the movie
in the beginning and you know he said
look it's pretty historically accurate
but we're making a movie here so you
know they took some Liberties and [__]
like that so you know don't go into air
looking for a historical document you
know it's a he described it as a fable
he's like it's an American Fable and
he's absolutely [__] right but
there's enough historical accuracy in
that movie like to ground it to a place
of like oh yeah this is based on true
events
um and they they spend like you know the
first [__] four minutes of the movie
is like an 80s [__] travelogue to set
the tone of where they were at the time
and what was going on even that alone
before the movie began proper the story
proper I had [__] joker-like grin on
my face just by Falling Down the 1984
[__] Rabbit Hole of like oh my God
like
it's it's a wonderful movie go see it
sweet so yes I think Ben would be a
lovely guest for a fat man 400 but we'll
think about it and we'll figure out when
exactly we're going to pull this off
once JC's back from uh Mary old England
oh dilf man what's up I just want to
point out as for guests as far as guests
go Davey sock rocker spent a buck 99 to
say Kevin James but he's right here
already
deep Cuts right there man since we're
going back to Super Chat Wyatt butts
paid 20 bucks to say what about a better
place made by viewsq historian uh
Vincent Pereira that will be coming to
smod Castle as well Mark my goddamn
words man just like we're showing
drawing flies uh on May 7th we'll be
showing a better place uh as well this
this maybe this summer I just came up
with a full summer schedule that I at
three in the morning and [__] sends it
to Ernie to be like this is what we're
doing we're doing we're leaning heavily
into the movies that made me series all
this summer so we're gonna bring you
[__] Goonies we're gonna bring you
[__] Beetlejuice we're gonna we're
gonna show you so many movies that you
could watch at home and we're gonna
overcharge you to watch some of this
podcast
Jaws we're gonna be showing [__] Jaws
coming up and stuff uh anyway everything
that's not owned by Disney
essentially yeah absolutely because kids
I don't know if you know this or not but
Disney does not like rep house they
don't like you showing their old [__]
they're I guess they're [__]
present and future and [__] so Universal
wonderful to work with Warner Brothers
wonderful to work with man Warner Bros
reached out and like do you want to show
Superman I was like [__] yes so we're
gonna be showing Superman the movie soon
um Paramount easy to work with uh the
list goes on Disney
they won't let you [__] touch one of
their old movies man like and that
includes now the fox Library when I was
on the road with the clerks the
convenience store I went to a lot of mom
and pop theaters and [__] and they were
all lamenting like the [__] loss of
the fox Library they can't show alien
anymore because Disney owns it and they
threw it in the vault and even it
doesn't matter if you're like please can
I [__] you even if you're like can I
show up for charity they're like no way
they don't they don't do that they just
don't play like that so like kids movies
as I said work insanely well at our
theater
so Ernie has been like programmed like
we had not only did we show the Muppet
movie but we had [__] uh Muppets Take
Manhattan for like a week and it
outgrossed current [__] movies and
[__] like that so Ernie was just like
what other kids movies can we show and
he started listing titles in every one
of them I was like we can't show The
Aristocats that's Disney we can't show
[__] that that's Disney we can't show
[__] Toy Story That's Disney and he
was like what so yes Disney don't like
to work with the rep house theaters at
all they live in the present and the
future
and I don't know why they won't [__]
deal with the past but
there it is anyway speaking of Disney
and the future
um we got a bunch of [__] news we got
a bunch of first looks of stuff some of
which have seeped into the the digital
ether for all of us to watch legally
some of which uh are still behind the
inside the Disney Vault but we we got
the trailer teaser trailer whatever
we're calling it for Ahsoka which is
coming this August
which we talked about earlier
um and looks like basically Rebels
season whatever the [__] but you know
awesome to see it come to life number
one like you know not just because I
know her but I [__] love Rosario
Dawson one of my favorite actors on the
[__] planet I was lucky enough to get
to work with her in some stuff some in
clerks too Jane zombob reboot clerked
three more recently
um she
absolutely destroys
in this [__] trailer she is Ahsoka
and it's so [__] wonderful we've seen
her be Ahsoka in a couple episodes in
Mandalorian and [__] Boba Fett but I
can't believe and I'm so happy that
they're giving this character on series
I'm so delighted that it's Rosario
Rosario who walks between all [__]
worlds man she's done DC work Marvel
work Star Wars work she wanted to do
Star Trek work as well yeah he tried to
make that happen we tried to move Heaven
and Earth but we just couldn't get it
done
um she's she's truly a fan I ain't even
gonna say she's a fan girl she's
practically a fan boy she loves the [__]
so much she's a fan person let's just
leave it at that mom who's also [__]
one of the greatest living actors we
have she's legit [__] wonderful and
everything one of my favorite
performances she ever gave was in um
uh Spike Lee's 20 25th hour one of my
favorite [__] movies of all time and
stuff but she wonderful in absolutely
everything and she looks fantastic in
this movie I don't mean just the look I
mean [__] her [__] whipping those
lightsabers into the ground and doing
this [__] and it's spinning they did
that once in [__] I think it was an
episode of rebels and [__] same [__]
trick you could tell Dave filoni deeply
deeply involved in Ahsoka very much so I
mean it seems as if I mean Dave filoni
being now the kind of you know the the
new George Lucas for the TV stuff
in in Star Wars is the I'm I know what
works I know what I love this has all
been sort of a long game so that I could
bring clone wars and Rebels to real life
and cast people who be great in it in
fact cats some of the people who did
their Voice work for the original stuff
I mean grand grand Elmo thrawn
you know whatever Mickelson they they
found the the Mickelson Farm they found
another Mickelson uh Lars I believe his
name is
um is now who was the voice of thrawn on
the cartoons is now going to be the live
action Grand Avenue and it's not even
like they got a robot playing him and
he's doing the voice is literally him as
the actor yeah he's [__] blue and
everything like that how awesome is that
man God bless Dave filoni and his funny
hat because this is a man who deeply
deeply cares about Star Wars I remember
doing an interview I think maybe it was
for The Tonight Show I forget who it was
but I was interviewing filoni and you
know it was at the time where you [__]
all over the [__] uh prequels and
[__] like that and he was the first one
to like stop me dead my track's not in a
shitty way to be like [__] you but he
was like you don't understand how
[__] beautiful those movies are and
he took me on a deep dive about the
Lucas prequels and [__] and he was right
like he he flipped me he flipped my
script completely that was before they
gave him the [__] keys to the kingdom
him in the Fabs I love what he's [__]
doing I love the fact that he's like you
know what ahsoka's just going to be
[__] rebels in live action I love
what we also heard which I guess might
be part of the news which is about what
he's how he's wrapping up Mandalorian
like you got it and it's it's really
really it's both smart from a story
perspective and smart from a financial
perspective which is you can't charge
people for Mandalorian really you get
the you get 14.99 to subscribe to Disney
plus and there's some merch that you can
get for sure but you can't get people to
buy stuff the way you used to you can't
charge them for admission the way you
used to this way now suddenly they're
making a Star Wars movie they're making
it big and now you get to make
300 400 million dollars domestically 500
600 internationally on a TV show that
you were giving people ultimately for
free
you know and like wrap it all up in a
movie put a nice bow on it like tell the
story of mandalore's final chapter the
story of din jarin and then young grogu
not being so young maybe learning how to
speak words I don't know any of those
things are possible but
women did they say when that's happening
they didn't they didn't put any dates on
it because I think they've they've since
learned their lesson do not promise
things in Star Wars land because it's
always a it's a shifting delicacy Buffet
um I think that the thing of the Ahsoka
trailer that that worked for me most was
Rosario because I never watched Rebels
so like I don't have a real connection
to these characters like I know oh
that's Sabine ran and here's thrawn and
there's I'm like I don't know who any of
those people are but I know who Rosario
is and I know who asoki is and I think
she's [__] she's so good
she just drags me into it even though I
don't have a real connection to it and
they gave her the billion dollar line in
the trailer where she's like where she
literally says heir to the Empire
and how sweet for him like those books
are no longer Canon and [__] but now
filoni found a way to kind of bring him
in and and make him Cannon he literally
had her say heir to the Empire for God's
sakes yeah that's fan service right
there kids uh you know remember earlier
in the chat somebody was like [__] on
Star Wars [__] on stores I can't when
somebody this cares this much when you
could feel the fandom like and that
trailer is nothing but [__] fandom
yeah like I I I spent some time in this
podcast shooting on Star Wars
um
In This Very episode [__] on Star
Wars
um but I I always come to these things
with hope you know because the first one
of these I saw it was a New Hope and so
I come to these With A New Hope every
time because you know and hoping that
they will recapture the thing that I
love about Star Wars
um it's been a while so but I I keep
watching a while
um and it seems as if Star Wars is
trying their [__] best because now
um Daisy Ridley is back Ray is back the
uh the movie that we'd heard announced a
couple years ago that Damon Lindelof and
Justin Gibson were writing that uh that
they have since left and is now being
written by Stephen Knight who he of
peaky blinders Fame directed by
Charmaine Obed chenoy who's behind Miss
Marvel is the return of Rey is the next
chapter in The Ray story so Rey's
getting her own movie or series she's
getting her own movie they're not
promising any series of anything anymore
at the very least there will be one
movie that according to Kathleen Kennedy
it's the story of the rebuilding of the
new Jedi Order and the powers that rise
to tear it down Rey will be the powerful
Jedi Master rebuilding the order
so [__] yeah like wait a second so
here's my question yes sir JJ Abrams do
you get a piece of that because like he
created Ray
um created Ray with a bunch of other
people I I imagine that it all belongs
to Lucasville
um probably does probably does I mean I
don't know if he has some kind of you
know sweeten the pot character creation
payments that he'll get a a piece of
he should he look how he he ain't on
Super Chat so I don't know how he's
making it
so give him a piece of Ray God damn it
Ray a drop of golden [__] cash yeah
wait so they announced a Mandalorian
movie or they're not necessarily calling
it Mandalorian movie but right but
that's Dave filoni's feature film is
probably going to sweep up the story of
Mandalorian booger Boba Fett and and I
think Ahsoka let me double check
and then they also announced a ray movie
then it was a rain movie and then James
Mangold announced the third movie
um which is set it's a Biblical epic
apparently
um said 25 000 years before any other
Star Wars content thus far
um his it's going to wrestle with the
ideas of where the force came from when
did we discover it and when did we learn
how to use it
normally I would be like what but
[__] James mangle is a fantastic
filmmaker I mean looking at the new
indie trailer oh my God how good is that
[__] trailer and they open with
[__] Sympathy for the Devil and [__]
yeah yeah
I mean and it's it it doesn't give away
very much of what the story is no it
doesn't you really don't it's a
masterful trailer in that way because I
think we all realize that they just half
the time they just tell us the movie in
the trailers here's this is the guy who
made 310 to Yuma [__] work this
who made [__] Ford versus frog I
didn't give a [__] about cars man and I
love that [__] movie this is a guy
who made Logan For Heaven's Sake this is
a guy what go on and on he's honestly
like the best of us I don't even include
myself as an Us in the [__]
directorial caliber of a James mangled
so you tell me James mangle is doing a
Star Wars story set long before [__]
Star Wars long before the prequels long
before the [__] Force even began
maybe the midi Floridian story whatever
the [__] normally I'd be like what but
it's that guy you got my money I'm
already on board this dude is a master
Storyteller it's that guy
um Kate and Leopold guy
deep Cuts deep medical guts I used to
work at Miramax uh if uh if you were on
the ground in London um for celebration
you got to see the first look at the
acolyte Leslie Headlands
um new series speaking of Miramax when I
met Leslie Headland she was my friend
John Gordon's assistant uh who worked at
[__] Miramax back in the day and then
I remember one day and she was like hey
man I wrote a play will you come see it
me and Moshi was like Yeah and I don't
think we ever did but I've watched her
quietly [__] Ascend men like I
remember she did though she wrote the
about last night remake and [__]
um now she [__] doing the acolyte
which is apparently amazing based on
reaction people had yeah we're not
seeing that right they're not putting
that online or anything they haven't put
it online yet
um apparently it's it's a prequel
Pre-Sequel said 100 years before
um the Skywalker Saga
um so it's in the high Republic when the
Jedi were just [__] everywhere uh
that Leslie Headland has described it as
Frozen meets Kill Bill in Pitch meetings
[__] yeah I mean what the [__] those are
three good words that I like Frozen
um Amanda Sternberg from um from the
hate U give and body's body's bodies is
in it Lee Jong Jae from squid game Jody
Turner Smith from Queen and slim and
Manny Jacinto from the good place and
was cut out of uh top gun Maverick are
all these sort of that's the cast that
they've that they're rolling with and so
what is that for that yeah all and
nothing but positive like feedback for
what they saw people been loving yeah
absolutely somebody pointed out Chad
hold on where is it uh Frasier Lomas
said Copland was great excellent [__]
point James mangle did [__] Copland
as well but algae 473 says but this
James Mangold know anything about Star
Wars or knowledge of Star Wars Lord
James Mangold is of a certain age I
think he's younger than me but anybody
who [__] grew up in the 70s watching
these movies kids knows their Star Wars
um I don't think that dude throws a SAT
into the [__] ring
like y'all saw Logan right yeah like
the man knows his his [__] he knows his
lure so I don't think he goes anywhere
near Star Wars unless he feels supremely
confident I mean this guy could get a
job anywhere so he certainly don't need
to jump on the Star Wars train if he's
doing that I think it's coming from a
place of Love also he you know [__]
he just did the Indiana Jones and dial
Destiny so obviously somebody there was
like hey man can you cross the street
and [__] come over to Star Wars and
they're lucky to have him that's what I
say yeah you know if he's got a story to
tell I mean you know I'm not going to
say that any writer can write anything
because clearly there are people who
have proclivities and talents in one so
versus another but that is a dude who
seems to like if he's interested in it
he will do deep [__] research in it
and then deliver like I don't know how
much of a wolverine he was a deep lore
fan of but Logan is the best X-Men
you know like I don't know if he could
give a [__] about Ford's end or Ferraris
but I love that movie yeah it's a great
movie you know and so like he just seems
to be a filmmaker who when he invests in
a thing and does the work in a thing can
just find and has a story he wants to
tell can find his way to make it work
and so I'm I'm here for whatever version
that is
um the funk bomb bro the game cat said
Kevin Smith needs to do a Star Wars
movie no he does not look I'm the
world's biggest Kevin Smith fan I'm here
to tell you he would drop the [__]
ball don't trust Kevin Smith with a Star
Wars anything you know what Kevin Smith
does references Star Wars and movies
that's the exact level of his talent
that's the glass ceiling that he's got
if they gave me the kings of the kingdom
and they were like you do whatever you
want
I'm not that imaginative like when it
comes to this [__] that's where I
stopped being a filmmaker and I just
resort to being a fan that's where all
this [__] came from why I do what I do
is because I grew up watching [__] like
Star Wars reading Marvel Comics and
stuff but I don't need to make that [__]
because I know my limitations and I'm
very limited kids very limited so I'm
the guy you want writing [__] where
characters talk about that [__] I'm not
the guy you want anywhere near Star Wars
anything unless
in a world where they're putting Jack
blacks and lizos and [__] Star Wars
things like
crabs I know a guy who's been talking
about this [__] for decades decades
and you know him call anyway
um we got some updates about Andor
season two hold on is that it for the
Star Wars movies did they say anything
about uh
Ryan Johnson's
um according to variety
um Catherine Kennedy to give an update
on Ryan Johnson I said that he is so
busy working on the next Benoit Blanc
film there might be some time before we
see Johnson's Star Wars movie I was
gonna say because my man's [__] like
stars on the
like Beyond on the rise he's now
legitimately part of the firmament and
[__] like that and he don't need Star
Wars at all I know some people get testy
about
you know [__] The Last Jedi or
whatever the [__] I you know you know
how I feel about the Last Jedi
um now between those [__] Knives Out
movies and what's the show he's doing
with Natasha Leone yeah Poker Face which
everybody [__] loves like he's an
institution and he don't even need Star
Wars so naturally it'll probably be a
few years before he gets there but I
think by the time he circles back after
he's done doing all his [__]
I bet you he does something [__]
special yeah you know so his movie is
coming but slowly and uh takeaway TD is
also working on a movie and according to
to Kathleen Kennedy he's still writing
his script he doesn't want to bring
others into that process and I don't
blame him he has a very unique voice so
we want to protect that and that's what
he's doing and we're gonna make that one
day whenever that day May Come
just said imagine if instead of Jack
Black and lizzo it was Kevin and Mark
I can't imagine that no totally I I
would happily [__] night grogu
and kissy face with Kevin as the gay
world we would be the ones jumping the
[__] Mandalorian shark if you will
um but nobody calls nobody cares yeah
nobody calls we sit here and blow this
[__]
two hands like the Saturday Night Live
sketch
um [__] every goddamn week but Fondo
ring and [__] no because I apparently
[__] on it every other week so is that
what's holding us back you could be it
could be you've hitched Your Wagon in
the Millennium Falcon right now I know
guys I'm right here
uh and or season two is coming
apparently uh August 2024 is this what I
read the last shot of Andor season two
goes right to the first shot of Rogue
one they consider Rogue one to be the
this and or season one and or season two
and Rogue one is a Trilogy yeah
according to Gilroy he said we know
exactly where we're going you have to
you know what you have to deliver
emotionally and what the story has to do
it's a decision board of survival but
it's good for us creatively uh
apparently season two will take place
over four years with each with four
three episode long pods telling a story
from each year
um and then it ends with with Rogue one
um I love Tony Gilroy and I never loved
him more than when he [__]
mentioned clerks in his round of press
he was just remember that scene from
clerks talk about the Star Wars
contractor Death Star contractors
and I was like what the [__] like did he
[__] just say what I thought he said
it was very sweet of him man uh Star
Wars obviously is a phenomenon that
influenced a great deal of my work to
have somebody in Star Wars even [__]
give me the tiniest [__] like oh yeah
there was a bit of influence there was
like [__] breathtaking to me
that being said I still haven't watched
all the indoor season one I will do so
good so good that's why I hear from
literally everybody everybody's like
dude it's the best Star Wars that has
existed in a while so I look forward to
finishing it nice
um two more little bits out of uh
celebration
um tales of the Jedi is getting um a
second season Dave filoni sort of
Anthology just kind of telling little
stories in and around the the continuity
wait what's that tales of the Jedi did
you not see season one of tales of the
Jedi the animated thing yes yes so what
Dave filoni did that yeah and now he's
going to season two in season two
um and also a season two of the Star
Wars Visions Anthology which was Star
Wars is interpreted by various animation
houses from all over the world is coming
back for season two on May the 4th
um and one of the ladies judging about
the trailer which did drop one of the
animation houses that's doing a Star
Wars short is ardman who did the Wallace
and Gromit cartoons and chicken and
Chicken Run and Flushed Away yes yes the
great [__] artman Studios oh awesome
so they're going to do stop motion
claymation
it looks so cool kids remember when
clerks came out if you were alive and
they would they talked about the Death
Star contractors when I when I wrote
that scene it was like oh man remember
Star Wars because we never thought we
were getting another Star Wars thing
ever again now all the Star Wars things
they will they will never not be a star
war between now and the time me and Mark
leave this [__] Festival
they're gonna there's gonna be Star Wars
forever man it's never gonna stop like
it's
and I'm here for it you know it's and
some people get kind of stinky about it
and [__] hey man make all the Star Wars
you can because
some of it will be great some of it
would just be okay but you know what as
a kid who grew up watching this [__] I'm
here for it I know some people are like
you can't get nostalgic for something if
it won't go away it's never going away
and
I'm I'm okay with that
um one other piece of Star Wars news
um that did not come from celebration
would drop just before it is Donald
Glover according to an interview with GQ
Magazine said that he is more than open
to playing Lando calrizine again
which I hear has happened right I mean
you know according to him
um it's gonna love to play Lando again
it was fun time to be in it just needs
to be the right way to do it
um since the pandemic he's he's not
interested in doing anything that's just
going to be a waste of my time or just a
paycheck I'd rather spend time with
people I enjoy but he has been talking
to lucasfilmer about playing Lando again
saying Landon was definitely somebody
I'd like to hang out with we're talking
about it but that's as much as I can say
without Kathleen Kennedy hunting me down
I'm here for it man I thought he did a
great job as Lando but if you come to
Orlando something I hope to God
it starts with Billy D Williams Lando
reminiscing about his younger days so
that we get to see him and then we get
to see uh Donald Glover and
like young Indiana Jones but with Lando
people with Lando young Lando Calrissian
just do that
um leaving uh a galaxy far far away and
returning to our current one
um Harry Potter uh seems to be shifting
into television
um the long rumors who knew who knew I
mean look we always knew that [__]
once they made money they're like all
right here's Fantastic Beasts and we
always knew they had like [__] the
cursed child waiting in the wings that
they could always do but I this is why
I'm [__] an idiot not a visionary
I'm like well Harry Potter's done they
did those movies they'll never do them
again and now they're like you're out of
your [__] mind do you know how many
Batmans there have been you know how
many Spider-Mans there are I guess how
many Harry Potters are gonna be before
you drop dead a lot so now they're
talking about doing a series on HBO Max
or whatever they wind up calling it yeah
I mean HBO Max potentially my if I had
to guess I'd say it's actually gonna end
up being HBO proper
um but uh but yeah and the idea the
general idea is for each season of the
potential TV series to focus on one book
in the Harry Potter book series which
consists of seven novels
I I would think that there's an entire
generation of kids who are like
sacrilege because Daniel Radcliffe is
the only Harry Potter but you know as
we've seen if it makes a dime it will
never end kids
own your childhood like they own ours so
I guess it makes sense I mean think
about it those movies you're putting
like [__] all those stories into like
two hour blocks two and a half hours
sometimes almost three
but the chance to actually [__] go
deep like balls deep with an episode The
episodic nature uh that covers literally
everything in the [__] books
you know makes sense I you know I I
would have never thought of it but I'm
not very Visionary I made three clerkses
so I I gotta imagine somewhere somebody
was like wait we could [__] do all
the books as opposed to just
[__] sections of the book man we can
go balls deep in the shin that's what
looks like what's gonna happen so
get ready for it you can't escape Harry
Potter no I mean I I 100 get it you know
that there was always going to be
another boy who lived even though the
current boy who lived is whatever 32
years old
um
it's weird that they're just retelling
the same stories
um that's the odd part like when you get
a new Indiana Jones when you get a new
Batman you get a new James Bond they're
not just remaking the old stuff that you
already saw once true and they've never
remade Star Wars they keep adding to it
it's not like like remember Star Wars
well here's the 2023 version of it same
[__] story a new hope they keep
holding on to their mythology but this
you're right this is literally
retreading the same story this is like
the road I'm not putting it in the same
class but you know how they remade
RoboCop like that's that's what's going
on here where they're just like oh we're
remaking it but we're just making it
longer and you can watch it on TV which
I guess makes sense
um speaking of uh how much you want to
bet though that they do the series and
then the [__] final books are movies
or whatever the [__] they're gonna take
their cues off of whatever happens with
Dave filoni wrapping up the Mandalorian
with its own [__] feature you better
bet that [__] Warner Brothers is
going to be like oh yeah it's a CV
series until it's a [__] movie we can
make a billion dollars off of them to
wrap this all up once we you know the
first [__] taste is not free we all
pay for HBO Maxwell some of us do
um but the [__] when when it comes to
the end
they're gonna probably make you shell
out to go see it in the movie theater
that would be my guess but you know what
I'll probably be dead by the time this
all ends because how many books they got
seven books seven books
by the time they get started let's say
it's like two years from now I'll be 54
seven books that takes me to 61. for
sure I'll be dead I'll never be the end
of this [__] thing you see how
enthusiastic I get about all this my
heart races and whatnot I'm a heart
attack victim and whatnot I got heart
ailments I'll probably be dead by the
time this all happens but I'm happy to
know it exists you know I think that I
think they'll do it fast enough that
you'll probably get to see it because
whatever kids they cast
you'll probably want to be the kids that
are in it that's such a good point I was
thinking about it today I was like boy
they gotta [__] make that show like
because those kids will hate
yeah kids do that you know unless they
find some kids from another world who
stay the same age and [__] and older
they stay the same age yes they do uh
they have to [__] keep it in real
time because kids get older man yeah I
mean look at the stranger things kids
we're all now like 28 in their 20s
they all got [__] mortgages and homes
like you still going to high school yeah
man like you can't like I bet you
well I mean look they got the books it's
not like they're like what's the story
gonna be right
um and it sounds like she's involved JK
Rowling he has to be that's her
contractors they can't do anything
without her so maybe before they shoot
if maybe they're gonna do it like David
Lynch did the Twin Peaks Series where
he's like here's the script
it's a 900 page script and we're gonna
shoot the whole thing at once that would
make sense but man oh man those kids
whoever they get those kids are gonna
miss out on a [__] childhood I'll
tell you right now because they believe
in the inside of that [__] brick
building they're gonna leave rich but
they're [__] Never Gonna experience
life because they're gonna have to make
Harry Potter every day for like at least
six years straight if not seven yeah you
know it's going to be the same thing
with the Game of Thrones kids right like
you know Arya Stark and easy Williams
was what like 12 or 13 when they started
and was 25 when they wrapped up and
like find these kids who can play Young
for a long time because they're going to
be working for a long time long time
um speaking of kids uh who grew up and
are growing out of their roles
uh Netflix has found a solution to their
stranger things issue I mean not the
least of which is that the upcoming
fifth season is going to be the end of
it but now there's an animated stranger
thing of things that is spinning out of
it I'm sorry so season five which is
that hasn't happened yet it's coming
correct that's going to be the end of
stranger things that's the end of
stranger things and now they're gonna do
an animated series yep
uh according to The Duffer Brothers uh
we've always dreamed of an animated
stranger things in the vein of the
Saturday morning cartoons that we grew
up loving
um and to see this dream realize it's
been absolutely thrilling we couldn't be
more Blown Away the scripts in our work
are incredible and we can't wait to
share more with you the Adventure
Continues
um we want to talk about some poor kids
who've been locked in a [__] brick
building for the last few years those
Duffer Brothers man yeah all they do is
stranger things and they got no choice
it's their their [__] baby and stuff
and but boy they've been working on that
since it before we all saw it and [__]
like that what will they follow it up
with I wonder
um well their their production company
signed a massive overall deal with
Netflix
um they are adapting they have plans to
adapt as TV series Death Note
um the manga slash anime series uh as
well as Stephen King's The talisman
there you go we got an answer look at
that I was wondering Mark filled in the
blanks that's when you come to the show
for knowledge knowledge knowledge
knowledge is power
um we got two more stories
um one of them is uh fun and the other
one is intensely Less Fun
um Ryan coogler apparently wants to
reboot The X-Files
let him let out of the [__]
Storyteller who's standing in his way
apparently nobody according to Chris
Carter who created The X-Files
um Creed and black panther director Ryan
cougar is looking to be at the helm of
this new project
the new take on the series which Carter
refers to as a remount
uh is is an apparent departure from the
X12 Albuquerque an animated comedy
spin-off that Carter was supposed to
produce in 2020.
um blah blah blah
let's see you know what I say to that I
say everybody clap your hands
clap clap clap your hands I would love
to see more X-Files and I would love to
uh Ryan coogler has not let us down once
no it's not even here for once so give
them all the X-Files will there be
Mulder and Scully or no uh it does not
seem that'll be Mulder and Scully um
according to Carter's quote I spoke to a
young man Ryan coogler was going to
remount The X-Files with a diverse cast
so he's got his work cut out for him
because we covered so much territory I
mean I guess technically he is a young
man but how weird to it's like when we
were like this kid Tim Miller about life
the guy into Deadpool is older than us
yes this young man
um and now for the it's hard to call his
bad news
um but the great Al Jaffe of Mad
Magazine Fame passed away at 102 years
old
are you [__] me yeah 100 I mean look
[__] nobody likes to lose anybody but
a hundred and two for the man the fold
in the man behind the folder
um uh the organ organ failure is the
cause of death
um after celebrating his 102nd birthday
last month wow um 102
102. this man was responsible for so
many happy moments in my childhood I was
an Ardent Mad magazine reader and fan
um it was weird that I didn't engage as
much with the Mad Magazine TV show The
Mad Show I was on it once
but like as much as I loved Mad Magazine
I mean nothing comes close I could still
sing it's uh great big beautiful
wonderful incredible super spectacular
day one of the albums they gave away
mad super special
um and Al Jaffe seeing his drawing
seeing his very singular artwork
um throughout all of my childhood and
well into my [__] adulthood as well
always made me happy this man was a
gifted artist and a funny one at that
um who holds a special place in my heart
with Don Martin
[__]
Severin guy that worked for like crack
magazine he started at [__]
or was it crazy cracked
um all those [__] people of my
childhood that like
wrote you know the humor magazines you
know National Lampoon came later when it
was more grown up and stuff but as a kid
[__] now jeffy's name was like as a
rock star name in my world still to this
day and I'm sad that he's gone but I'm
happy to know that he lived to be a
hundred and [__] two years old I've
been [__] two
um the first fold-in was in 1964.
um inspired according to to jaffee by
the centerfolds and Playboy and other
magazines
um and let's see a four volume hardcover
box set called The Man folding
collection
1964-2010 was published uh about 10
years ago by Chronicle Books
um
his final fold-in was published in the
magazines August 2020 Jaffe tribute
issue and services farewell upon his
retirement at age 99.
he was still he drew a [__] fold in
at age 99 well he stopped drawing in 99.
it was drawn six years before he
initially to be published as death the
unfolded illustration depicts mad mascot
Alfred E Newman beneath a slew of bad
news out of business signs when folded
these sides instead read no more new
Jackie foldings with a peaceful looking
portrait of jappy of Jaffe floating
Above The Fray
that's beautiful and so what they
published it long before his death so he
got to see it published he got he got to
see it published
um he created more than 500 back cover
fold-ins
um covering things from Jesus Christ
from Bill Mania to president Donald
Trump's proposed health care plan
wow man that guy that guy kept working
yeah that's recent history
in a in in 2016 he was recognized by the
Guinness World Records as a longest
working cartoonist in comics history did
he did they list anything else he did
and are we forgetting like he did he do
Snappy answers to stupid questions he
did
indeed and uh let's say remember my
childhood I remember
yeah he started it mad in 1955 he
briefly left work left there to work on
uh the short-lived humbug human magazine
he returned in 58 and yes he contributed
the popular features Snappy answers to
stupid questions
Legend absolute [__] Legend and he
deserved to live as long as he lived I
mean unless you know that was painful or
whatever the [__] because he that guy
deserves no pain whatsoever I'm sorry
his organs shut down but my God [__]
hey I don't know what is responsible for
us somebody in the chat said we need to
accept Jesus as Lord or whatever earlier
on I don't know about I can't speak to
how we're here why we're here and
[__] who put us here if anybody did
but I think
whatever good Lord or [__] force of
the universe is out there that led a man
who brought brought that much [__]
Joy palpable joy in this world let him
live to be a 102. nobody wants to die I
don't think
um and I'm glad he didn't for a long
long ass time [__] I hope those last
years weren't as you know [__]
terrible as
as it can be when you know in a world
where your [__] organs shut down I'm
[__] man he just missed them finding the
Cure keep reading about their finding
the cure for death they're going to be
able to prolong Our Lives even more
guy like that would have deserved
another [__] 20 man
all those mad artists and writers
you know
made me so happy throughout my childhood
part of what I do today you know in my
creative DNA you'll find a lot of Mad
Magazine and whatnot Jane Silent Bob
Strike Back what is it if not a a mad
movie special for heaven's sakes I mean
it's kind of like the Muppet movie with
dirty words in it but it owes a lot to
Mad Magazine and I owe a lot to Al Jaffe
he always put a [__] smile on my face
just when you were done with [__] Mad
Magazine they had one more [__] joke
and that was the fold-in and let's be
honest most of us started with the
folded anyway
uh pour one out for the great Al Jaffe
[__]
yeah
um yes Matt will post in the in the chat
is like they're finding a cure for death
yeah every once in a while I read that
online and I graze the article and I'm
like [__] hey do it do it in my
lifetime I mean look finding the cure
for death would be great finding the
cure to stop [__] aging would be even
better because I don't want to look like
you know what you don't see right here
kids is I uh I if you came in late I was
uh busy doing [__] uh
Silent Bob earlier today
and uh Emily who does my makeup and [__]
she colored in all my whites that
normally would see my beard so if I look
particularly young that's you know the
[__] Glory of makeup and [__] like
that the whites are moving in they're
gentrifying the [__] out of my face and
I can't stand it
um it's it's unavoidable ages unless
somebody [__] cures it because I
would like to be this age forever I
always thought I would have liked to be
18 forever and [__] but 52 is not
[__] bad man uh no I remember reading
something God it was a couple years ago
that was just saying that like they
don't really know why
people die of natural causes like
they're never they're never entirely
sure what the medical reason for it is
other than it just happens all the time
100 of the time
um people die but they're like yeah the
body technically should not run out of
gas you know like we can replace most of
it if we need to like we can give you
new heart we can give you we can give
you a transplant we can rebuild your
knees we can give you pacemakers we can
you know we can get you new we can
[__] take you into the shop and give
you an entirely new innards but why do
people still die anyway and they just
don't have an answer for that and so I
think that's the Cure quote unquote cure
they're trying to figure out it's just
an answer to that question of why
why even if we replace everything
you're still going to pass away
uh in chat Jim Tomlin says nothing on
Super Mario Brothers we did kind of talk
about it how much money it made and
stuff like that and it's probably going
to wind up being the highest grossing
film at smod Castle Cinemas by tenure
the movie just keeps making [__]
money for us particularly we get a lot
of kids in Atlantic Highlands at smart
Castle Cinemas uh but I haven't seen it
and Skippy Mark didn't see it so much
more we can't say about it other than
until we see it
uh we did talk about it so
I also wonder like I know that La USD is
the school district the like second
biggest school district in the country
in Los Angeles was on spring break last
week and so if you're gonna open a
[__] movie the best time to open a
kids movies when kids are not in school
I don't know how much around the country
that spring break happened to sync up I
don't know what jerseys was like but um
but that would explain some of the
reason why it did gross as much as it
did
uh Gina Ziegler who goes to like all of
our [__] mod Castle events man she's
a
a smog Castle keeper right next to Ernie
O'Donnell she said that's been packed at
smodcast Castle she talked about Super
Mario Brothers deep lying man like like
I said earlier in the show smodcast
keeper Ernie O'Donnell texted me in the
middle of the night to tell me how
[__] good how great that Super Mario
Brothers did on the Wednesday opening
its mod Castle we may build a [__]
statue
to Super Mario Brothers It's mod Castle
Cinemas because that's the only movie
[__] have come out to see other
than us showing like Mall Rats and stuff
like that see now you should you should
program in the old Super Mario Brothers
but don't tell people
who made that I mean I feel like there
was a new line movie
um maybe I saw an article I guess it was
in variety or something where they
talked to the directors I mean those
poor sons of [__] I think they're a
married couple they took a lot of [__]
when that movie came out back in the day
but they just showed it out here at
Quentin's uh Cinema the new Beverly you
know he loves Prince and they still got
a print of that movie and stuff do you
know there was no print ever made of
Tusk because we shot digitally and
[__] you know blah blah but Quentin
called and requested he was like can I
make a print of tusk and that ain't
cheap anymore to make a print you know
it used to be like two three grand back
in the day now it's one long [__]
effect shot but he's such a Michael
Parks fan that he was like I want to
print and because he don't show digital
at his theater and you know they used to
back in the day but he won't do it
anymore he's got like a massive [__]
library of 35 millimeter so um he he was
on his podcast with Roger Avery talking
about talking up the Super Mario
Brothers movie and then they showed it
at the new Beverly to a packed house and
[__] and the article and variety was
very warm talking the directors who were
like you know Quentin likes it and he
said nice things about him they went to
the screening and they were like
everybody was laughing in all the right
places
it's nice when [__] could get a
second bite of the Apple because boy
they they took it on the yoga hoser's
chin back when that movie came out gives
me hope that one day people will be like
yeah yogers wasn't that bad I doubt it
but it gives me hope
everything comes around true everything
fine that's the end of the news my
friend that's it that's it yeah two
hours and 45 minutes so much [__]
news oh my God give it up for Mark
Bernard and for giving you all the news
in chat is there anything we missed that
you guys [__] wanted to what the [__]
is this poisonous plants 15 said did you
guys discuss Clayface potentially being
the villain in the Batman 2 is that a
thing
somebody being like discussed I hope so
that'd be [__] wonderful but I don't
know how they do that because he he
likes doing that [__] real right like
[__] that Batman the Batman was all
about how [__] close to reality so I
don't know how to get away with Clayface
unless they do the
uh Boris Carlo version of the character
who is a guy an actor and [__] like that
as opposed to the hulking [__]
Clayface
um
that we missed I can't imagine
that you know one thing that I didn't
mention when I was at the Overlook Film
Festival I got to see Renfield
oh [__] what yeah that was uh the
opening night film of the festival was
Renfield and it's super fun it is super
fun like best casting on the planet a
[__] Nicholas Cage is just going for
it you know in every way you want
Nicholas Cage to go for it
um and Nick Holt is uh is is amazing I
mean the thing about the movie is and
I'm not going to spoil very much but I
think it's there in the trailers is that
it's a real it's just a big gloss on
codependency it's a big gloss on a guy
who's got a domino boss one of my
favorite subjects as of late
codependency you know who just feels
like he can't live without him and so
he'll do anything to please him and but
he's awful for him you know like there's
no nothing good comes from a
relationship for Renfield between him
and Dracula but he can't leave and so
making it about that is actually really
smart and and all of the ways you get to
play that kind of relationship Dynamic
is really really well done
there's another kind of place Renfield
it's the Beast yeah
it's the Beast it's uh it's nux he's
shining in Chrome into into Valhalla
um that's right yeah oh my God you're
right and the above there's many other
things the titular boy and about a boy
um and also wasn't he in that Catherine
the Great series or whatever the [__]
that's great great yeah
um very talented and it's super gory but
not like scary gory but just like pulpy
gory and how how great is Nick Cage he's
he's
he went full cage
I already shaved his teeth down I mean
he might have shaved his teeth down to
like put in the appliances that are his
teeth but like those ain't those teeth
that's some [__] up makeup [__] there
um but I love the fact that we're kind
of coming back to realizing exactly how
amazing an actor Nicholas Cage is yes
you know because he was in the in the
wild for a while like he would just do
whatever like you want me to do this
direct-to-video thing over here sure you
want me to be in the in this dumb weird
ass movie that nobody's gonna see that
we shoot in Bulgaria for 87 sure I just
gotta work and then kind of the Mandy
stuff came back around and then like
Colorado space came around and pig came
around and people beginning to realize
like this brand of weird is a thing that
you can actually kind of Channel and
bottle and when you can uncork it the
right way it's phenomenal it's mod bless
Panos cosmatos for casting a cage in
Mandy I I'm not going to say that's
where he [__] The Comeback began but
like he got he got Nick Cage to Nick
Cage and and was the movie you did
recently with uh uh Pedro Pascal the
[__] oh unbearable unbelievable
weight of unbearable genius or something
wonderful absolutely wonderful [__]
enjoyable ass movie well made funny as
[__] like
and to say only Nick Cage could do it is
you know [__] an understatement to
say the least man
um Nick Cage one of my favorite actors
going way the [__] back to Valley Girl
which is having its 40th anniversary uh
this year and they asked me to moderate
a q a at the Chinese Theater I don't
know if they've announced this yet but
if they haven't they better announce it
soon because it's coming up
um April 27th I think it is like I'm
leaving cinemacon a day early so I can
come back here and moderate the valley
girl screening I don't know if Nick Cage
is going or not I don't know who's
involved but they were like we hear you
like it I was like [__] yeah I love that
movie it's one of my favorite movies of
all time this movie that taught me about
love amongst many other movies and stuff
um but that one especially that was my
Romeo and Juliet God damn it oh um and
he was he's go watch that movie if you
haven't seen valley girl ever or lately
you're talking but you can see from that
movie that that dude was the man to
watch and I have watched him ever since
then my whole career
um he's been many things but [__]
he'll always be Randy in valley girl to
me so [__] I told him when I did I
moderated I interviewed him at
Sundance when I was doing IMDb
interviews and I also was the moderator
on a Mandy screening that him and Panos
went to and stuff and I got to tell him
I was like bro everything I know about
being a guy involved with a girl I
pretty much stole from [__] valley
girl and that's you and he was like oh
Kevin University and then he [__]
complimented Tusk bro
before it was fashionable he was like
and let me say Tusk and he said some
nice [__] about Tusk up my heart [__]
I almost vomited my heart up here is it
because I was like a man whose work I've
always loved and [__] like literally
loved us believe me if I make a Tusk
sequel one of the first [__] phone
calls I'm making is to Nick Cage but
he'll probably be too big now to do a
Tusk thing but he was a big fan of
Michael Parks I think that's why he
watched the movie but he loved it he may
be a big fan of Justin long as well
got engaged to Lois Lane did you see
that no yeah so uh
um Lois Lane from uh you know uh what
was the Superman movie called Superman
Returns
um oh
what is the actual name oh my God
hey Boswell Kate Bosworth I was like yes
he's been [__] in love
for a while now and [__] and he put up
an Instagram post about like [__]
them getting engaged and [__] and then I
saw it I said I [__] put in my
comments I was like she said walrus yes
which is deep you know [__] Tusk
um so happy for him he's such and happy
for her because let me tell you
something Justin long is a [__] catch
man
like I you know I love my wife but I'd
leave her for Justin long he's [__]
the ideal man because he's funny as [__]
talented as [__] and I think he I bet
you I bet you ten thousand dollars he's
a hell of a lover
hmm
uh he seemed like a very nice dude when
I met him uh uh when we did um what's
him called Family Feud Family Feud I
know he kicked our asses him and his
whole [__] team and [__] yeah oh he's
he's I love Justin long to death even
one of my favorite actors on the planet
and very much like a Nick Cage where
it's just like
he [__] commits and does [__] nobody
else does
um what is that [__] movie he was
just in Barbarian
such a great [__] flick
um but anyway congratulations and
congratulations congratulations no I was
right
congratulations now that I'm not stoned
all the time I'm like is that the right
word
um congratulations to the great Justin
long and capable man I don't know which
one made out better in that relationship
look him I know and her I just know her
work and I will say this
she was a she's [__] lucky woman to
snap that guy up he's a catch anyway
anyway so uh so yeah that's the news
that's all we got to say
um Redden field is also fantastic so I
think it's up it's Friday so uh so yeah
go see it I can't wait I'm hoping that
he shows up for that Valley Girl
screening
um
uh and you know it's in town so maybe he
will especially with Renfield being so
huge and stuff
um but fingers crossed
all right kids good God so much news we
did it for hours and hours and hours and
that means there's only one part left to
the show and ladies and gentlemen you
know what that part is oh somebody said
hold on and things we missed they were
like what about
[__] uh
um
uh Scott Pilgrim they're doing a Scott
Pilgrim cartoon is that correct indeed
for Netflix yeah
so [__] let me tell you something I
got the entire cast back that was a that
was pretty astounding but you know those
kids all love that [__] movie and God
bless him for standing by when the movie
came out you know I remember Edgar bless
his heart
like you know it was hurting at the box
office he stayed with that [__] movie
he went everywhere with that movie
he [__] stood by it believed in that
goddamn movie and then that movie of
course had its bucket you know very
quickly once it went to home video
that's when [__] its audience founded
I guess and [__] people absolutely
adored so I'm happy for them and they've
got a cartoon coming their way indeed
um and then somebody else asked about
another thing let me see
um
I don't know but we pretty much hit
everything
[__] man I mean you heard all that news
oh dilf what do you got well I'm just
saying are you actually gonna ask for Q
a when like the entire opening of the
show for like 30 minutes was q a are you
kidding me in a world where they're
paying for Q a on Super Chat
[__] yes we'll take all their goddamn
questions man uh wait stay uh EC Rose
said did you talk about the Barbie movie
trailer
we didn't we did not
certainly is a trailer
yeah so I'm here I'll be honest with you
I haven't seen it yet I saw all the
[__] pictures online but I've I have
not seen the Barbie trailer yet I will I
look forward to it I love both of those
kids Margot and [__]
too
simulu is in it um
yeah I mean it's it's Shang Chi yes in
the Barbie trailer he's in the Barbie
movie I'm sorry it took me this long to
remember Ryan Gosling that's his last
name
Canadian boy's last name what a great
there's another [__] great actor man
and funny as [__] do you ever see him on
SNL like anybody who goes to SNL and
kills earns my [__] lifelong respect
and I know he's a wonderful actor and
he's always been wonderful and
everything but like seeing that dude
[__] crush on SNL
does my heart good man yeah
did you see this weekend with Molly
Shannon yes and I was so [__] happy
for her uh yeah her big return she did
oh come on it's Molly Shannon man
how could she not do well and she
resurrected that character that comedian
character that's like can I tell you
have you seen this uh Genie Janine
Dorsey I forget what her name is
um
all right somebody said Kevin doesn't
see things anymore Benjamin said that I
do I see a lot of things I just haven't
seen the [__] Barbie trailer
um
Scott Pilgrim is in Barbie too what do
they mean by that [__] Michael
Sarah's and Barbie yeah he's got a
massive cast I love iron in it so what
the [__]
um I love Michael Sarah man Michael
Sarah of course I love him from Arrested
Development and other things he's done
but one of my favorite Michael Sarah
roles is in Molly's game movie with
Jessica Chastain where he essentially
plays Toby Maguire and [__] like Michael
Sarah has always been like sweet Michael
Bluth kid but [__] man and of course
he's been Scott Scott Pilgrim but him as
[__] you know the poker player with
no soul whatsoever
he pulled that [__] off I watched that
movie a lot and he's so [__] great in
that movie
um anyway anyway
Josh mundahl who [__] paid way too
much money to ask questions in Super
Chat said this free thing Gosling the
nice guys that shows his comedic chops
exquisitely
when exactly Josh he literally does like
an Abbott and Costello when he's next to
the tree and there's a dead guy next to
him he's like and [__] like that oh my
God he's so [__] good in that movie
excellent call
uh
okay
I guess are there any real questions are
they just shouting things in the chat uh
no I mean these now there are people
just I was seeing if like we missed
anything
Dungeons and Dragons you see it I did
see it and did we talk about it or no I
don't think we did I think we did uh I I
dug it you know like Chris Pine is doing
a lot of heavy lifting in uh in that
movie and he's so Charming [__]
one of my favorite current actors
working today man that
him out years ago was that movie he did
smoking and I remember like before that
movie came out he was like bro there's a
guy I worked with he's got his name and
he told his Christmas and he goes this
kid is [__] phenomenal and when I saw
the movie I was like oh [__] he's right
he is really good then he became [__]
Captain Kirk yeah um he was like you
know the best part of Wonder Woman 84
when he was like do people wear
parachutes nowadays like his his
delivery is so [__] good man and his
dad was that dude from chips the boss on
chips yeah yeah yeah that's a great
great [__] actor anyway so he's good
in this movie he's very good he's very
really Charming it's a ton of fun like
it's not deep but it's also not aiming
for depth you know it it tells some very
predictable kind of character stories
but it's um it does what you wanted to
do which is not give you the feeling of
playing d d because I don't think that's
a that's possible
um but it's just it's a [__]
Adventure you know it's just this little
Lark where we're just we're traction off
into the wild to you know save the guy's
daughter from the evil who's he wants
and there's dragons and there's Dungeons
and there's evil sorceresses and
yeah I mean it's it's not there's not a
ton to say it's just fun
uh Michael Morales and chat said the one
and he's not the only one who brought
this up so apologies to whoever else
brought this up the one and only return
is coming back to theaters for its 40th
anniversary smodcast Castle screening
this is the first I'm [__] hearing
about it so we were just talking about
how Disney has evolved and they won't
[__] let anything out
do you mean to tell me they're going to
re-release [__] Return of the Jedi in
theaters did you hear this yeah for its
40th anniversary when's that may
um when they used to open every Star
Wars movie in May yeah it would be
it would be man if they give us half a
[__] shot you better damn skippy
believe we'll be showing [__] Return
of the Jedi it's mod Castle Cinemas go
to smartcastlecinemas.com and look at
the coming soon section man there's a
kind of a ton of cool [__] coming up but
oh my God I mean look I was gonna show
them what is it April 28th I was
that's coming up man it's two weeks I
gotta get in touch with small Castle
keeper Ernie O'Donnell and make sure
that he [__] programs that and [__]
um and I'll be there I think April 28th
I think I'm around for some other [__]
going on at that point
uh let me tell you man [__] I was
gonna show it anyway [__] Disney but
now that they're legit yeah don't tell
them that but now that they're
legitimately letting it go back to
theaters [__] yeah it'll be at smodcast
Castle Cinemas
God yes if they give us half a [__]
chance give us a chance Disney
um okay
um shall we q a it up if we have some
cues
that we haven't already ate William
coats Smith is stuck on the f word
you're just noticing now I've been doing
this job 30 [__] years uh all I know
how to say is [__]
um and all I know how to do is [__] too
I could testify to that yes dilfman sure
can tell us stealth man what brings you
into these proceedings uh well aside
from all the wonderful people that are
probably gonna super chat now I do have
if you want them to ask the these
questions three
I didn't what you picked them yeah I
picked them at random I'm like oh that's
cool did you pick them from Super chat
or were you charismatic super chatter in
there
look at you but you kept so one from a
super chatter and two from the normal
ass plebs who don't pay for questions
well yeah because they were good
questions I thought I I could be proven
wrong within moments oh [__] man
somebody just paid 220 something what's
that what dollar figure is that wow I'm
guessing it might be something from the
Indian area with INR in it
says we want Kevin's rrr review please
make it happen Mark he needs to see this
and we fans need to see him gush about
it oh Cameron
um somebody just said before Kevin
doesn't see anything anymore and that's
not true but you're right about this
because I have not seen RR I've come
very close a few times based on Mark's
Beyond enthusiastic review of it holy
[__]
um so I I will get to it promises I'm
gonna get to it man uh you know I
watched last night I mean this is so not
[__]
you know from our world of genre but
[__] Emily the criminal with Aubry
Plaza was it good such a good [__]
movie she's like legit man like you know
I know everyone loves around like Parks
and Rec and [__] like that but like it
was a damn good movie and here's one
other thing we should talk about but I
don't want to spoil it but I gotta
[__] say something
is anyone watching succession
I I have never watched succession so
you're you're safe with me I'm with that
dude
you [__] neither of you have watched
succession I've heard it was like I was
gonna get into it I heard it the last
season so I'm like I'll wait
this show it has come out it is the last
season but they did a [__] thing on
last night's episode
unbelievable and one of the best
episodes of Television I ever saw
um my God the acting on this show is
[__] phenomenal and uh I think the
guy's name is Jesse Armstrong who
created It Maybe I'm Wrong
took a bold [__] choice and Ram with
it and it [__] paid off like it was
it was just [__] incredible
um if you're not watching succession if
you haven't watched succession like
these [__] numb nuts
get get to HBO [__] or HBO Max
wherever the [__] they run it I watch it
on HBO Max and watch the [__] out of it
man it's phenomenal and the last an
episode they did last night was
[__] spellbinding a spellbinding
piece of drama turgey kids
fair I don't want to spoil anything but
[__] it ain't look it ain't just all
cousin Greg I love [__] Nick and he's
amazing on that show but for everybody
on that in that show everybody in the
cast is just [__] mind-bendingly good
um and and yeah [__] the Culkin kid
[__] Brian Cox Brian Cox the original
[__] Hannibal Lecter Manhunter
um uh Jeremy what's his name Jeremy
maybe I'm wrong I don't know if I can
look oh they're all [__] great in the
show uh but man they did an episode last
night where I was like I can't believe
uh [__] I can't believe what they did
it was astounding in any event back to
the original question I will watch
[__] rrr you should
it's great
um okay uh stealth man
who is a real big [__] Super Chat
snob and [__] and he said it's going to
ruin the show and he's probably right
[Music]
um is taking the job seriously he's
picked three questions from the audience
only one from Super Chat uh [__] two
from the normal ass people who've
supported this show forever and whatnot
uh he's gonna bring us into the Q a man
which may go longer than three questions
because if I see [__] serious money
going up on that Super Chat you better
believe I'm gonna answer that question
hold on let me flip that switch real
quick yeah
and it'll just be Kev here's [__]
answering questions like going on hour
five
um Josh mundahl backs me up with a super
chat 4.99 but he don't have to pay more
he [__] overpaid us before he said
succession is what billions could have
been I only watched season one of
billions and I kind of fell off not
because it was bad just because like
there were other things to watch he says
if you're into a very Sorkin Style Show
I don't even know if I would consider
succession a Sorkin Style Show I don't
mean to argue with somebody who's put so
many [__] dollars into the Super Chat
tonight
but it's succession is really quite I
saw somebody describe it as like [__]
Dallas or Dynasty in the current age but
it ain't that it's it's I don't know how
to describe it except I've I've never
enjoyed watching rich people on TV I'm
not like one of those people like my mom
when we used to watch Dynasty when I was
a kid she just you know oh my God look
at the wealth like she didn't give a
[__] about the story man she was all
about how rich everyone was and [__]
this is one of the only [__] stories
about rich people that I've ever enjoyed
in my life
um
but I don't even know if that's the
right way to sell it it's just a great
piece of drama just setting the world of
the [__] sickly rich
uh anyway over to delft man sitting in
for Banff man who is over in the UK If
You're joined us late Banff man did a
wonderful [__] six minute piece from
celebration
uh Star Wars celebration over in the UK
go watch that but
while he's gone [__] dilf man is all
over this [__] dilfman's gonna give us
some questions dilfman take it away this
show has been going on for a thousand
hours now I don't want to say it feels
that way what time do we start
uh after my imposed delays I think about
6 10 6 13 maybe so so it's been over
three hours and yeah and we're nowhere
close to stopping because now we've got
the Q a
anybody else in the audience but I've
been having a good ass [__] time
tonight man like I miss all this [__]
when we didn't do it for a few weeks I
was [__] fiending man for a fix now
we're [__] pop culture junk
so you ready
all right oh I want to teach you about
our show a little more yes it's your
show uh the dorky review show who was
our super janitor that contributed
wonderful ten dollars thank you so much
ask the question if Marvel gave Mark and
Kevin the Reigns to write a Multiverse
scene in the next Deadpool where
Deadpool and Wolverine land in the DC
Universe verse for a bit what iconic
scenes or characters would you have them
interact with
so it's in the DC Universe yes but still
in a Deadpool movie with Wolverine so
Deadpool 3 mythical scene
what what Infamous scene do you have
them drop in from the comics or what
characters do you have them go with my
first instinct is Bane breaking Batman
[Music]
so that Deadpool can make fun of [__]
Batman for getting his back broken
something that
you know [__] Deadpool can't be
[__] killed as we've seen over and
over again so I think there's humor to
be mine there uh my next spot would be
uh flash on the cosmic tread Bill the
treadmill tread pill treadmill in
[__] uh crisis
and my next [__] scene would be
doomsday spoilers doomsday kill Superman
20-year spoilers uh I'd have him jump in
on that scene those are three
you only asked for one I gave you three
mark
um
I I feel like I want Deadpool and
Wolverine
to drop in on uh
a sound of her wings in the Sandman
just to talk about how [__] mopey
dream is like look at this [__] pale
ghost what's your big what's your damage
dude and then to have Logan get to talk
to death about
I won't die yeah you will no I won't
haven't done it yet been live for 400
years not gonna die anytime soon [__]
you [__] you Thin White Duke [__] you
um they're a Crime Alley I think Crime
Alley is just waiting for humor oh my
God what an excellent [__] pull how
many jokes they can make about those
[__] pearls
excellent pull excellent poll right
there because that's one of the most
solemn moments in DC history
responsible for giving us one of the
most solemn [__] heroes in the world
yes you're absolutely right it's ripe
for parody yeah what's that kid so
[__] sad about I don't know that was
Hispanics maybe maybe he's just a sad
[__] kid maybe he killed them hey kid
did you kill those two people
or just happened be like why didn't you
[__] kill the guy that killed your
parents yeah it's [__] nut up kid
[Music]
oh your mother's dead oh sorry about
that
cheer up Cheer Up Charlie thank you
[Laughter]
um before delfman comes back uh somebody
said uh Kalyn baby and Chad said did you
talk about Michael Lerner we did not the
great Michael Lerner passed away
um what a wonderful actor he was and
many wonderful roles including John
hamburg's safe man where he played big
fats but
I believe he [__] won an Oscar or at
least was nominated for Barton Fink if
I'm correct which still to this day
remains one of my favorite performances
of all time his [__] moments in the
sun in [__] Barton Fink
are phenomenal when I saw that he passed
away instantly I went to YouTube and
watched all of his scenes in Barton
thing him is the head of the studio
he's the one that's like we all have we
all want that Barton Fink feeling but I
assume you have it in Spades because
you're him and his life where he's like
because I've got Horse Sense God damn it
Showmanship oh he's so fantastic he's
the writer's King at Capital pictures uh
a wonderful performer and a wonderful
performance but yes he passed away damn
nominated for fake but did not nominate
thank you he should have [__] won Not
only was he [__] nominated and should
have won best supporting they should
have given him best actor he's so good
in that go to YouTube enter Barton Fink
Michael Lerner and watch those scenes
it's just a [__] Clinic
on Fast talking comedic performance is
wonderful he will be missed uh tough man
come on back
still
okay thank you that's wonderful I'm not
giving my answer because I don't have
enough reference you know all of my
stuff is I would just literally have
them fall into any Random episode of the
Super Friends that's what I would do
you know what not bad not bad
considering that you're [__] you know
not as armed as the rest of us with this
nonsense not bad as you can see there's
an Iron Man there's a Spider-Man there's
a Captain America shield so you know
where [__] Will's heart is
you don't go deep on DC that's a good
pull right there man well this is what
happens when you get your uh your bamf
man off wish that's all I'll say
uh okay you ready for the next question
yes
suddenly went into game show mode uh Z
Howard 1992 asked uh if you had the
cupboard from Indian in the Cupboard
what childhood toys of yours would you
put in it and how would they interact
wow that is a great question what an
excellent goal
um if I go like this and you never see
this part of the room and [__] like that
like there's a big giant naked portrait
of my wife over there and stuff
um on this shelf right there over here
are all pieces of my [__] childhood
[__] that like I used to own as a kid
and still own as an adult that came
directly from my childhood in 21 Jackson
Street so I'm gonna look at this shelf
and tell you what it would be okay I got
a McDonald's Playland
said
um it wasn't by fish I think Fisher
Price made it or maybe it was a place
called I forget who made it but it
wasn't the round old Fisher Price
figures and [__] these were square and
the there was one of them you know one
of the came with like uh it was at
McDonald's and it has the big sign and
inside you can move the fast food trays
the trays with stickers of the fast food
and [__]
and the McDonald workers are represented
by wearing individuals they don't wear
hats anymore at McDonald's as we all
know and stuff but that figure the one
of them I I you know I'll grab it it was
called I called the figure my little man
you know how like kids carry a blanket
like they're silky or they're [__] uh
what do they call that [__] like [__]
nubby no [__] was it when you when
you call like a security blanket like
linuses you're wubsy like a wooby like a
woman that was the word I was searching
for this McDonald Land figure which I'll
go grab when
um you know uh Mark does his answer and
[__] uh was my [__] whoopie and I
took it everywhere and the thing is it
became so worn that the head could come
off of it very easily but then I turned
him into the Invisible Man because like
you could [__] make him Invisible by
his head comes off and then [__] the
body goes away and [__] like that
um I would bring my little man to life I
know everyone's thinking about my dick
no that's not what my little man is it's
this figure from my McDonald lands
playset now this is not the original
McDonald's playset
that [__] probably went in the
garbage years ago thank you mother I
went and bought one of these online so I
could re-buy a piece of my childhood and
[__] I said look Disney can't have it
all and so I went and bought this
mcdonaldland's playset and so it sits on
my shelf uh more indicative of my youth
not an actual [__] Remnant from my
youth
um I would I would bring my little I put
my little man in the cupboard I'd bring
my little man to life and we'd be best
friends again just like we were in my
childhood the other thing I'd grab
probably
uh they made this remember the SST
things where you pull it back oh yeah
launch it I got a series of Snoopy
ssts man from childhood
um I was a big peanuts fan and remain a
big peanuts fan
um and I played this thing forever
Snoopy became my next little man I would
carry that around because you could take
a rubber Snoopy put him in the [__]
motorcycle it had some of the
motorcycles broke apart and [__] like
that I'd [__] bring that [__] to life
number one me and Snoopy would finally
be friends in real life number two
Snoopy drove a motorcycle and some of
them had side cars and I would happily
sit next to a motorcycle driving Snoopy
this is the man who flew the SOP with
camel when I say man I mean dog
um so I would do that and then for a
third
oh my God
Weebles
Weebles wobble but they don't fall down
that's right Mark remembers
um I'd bring a Weeble to life and [__]
like that uh because I love [__]
Weebles I had the Jaws game you know we
put [__] in his mouth and he pitch pull
[__] off and then it Chomps your clothes
and [__] and that's how you lose
so I would play jaws with because they
didn't have Jaws action figures back in
the day but they did have this Jaws game
but my three Weebles one was Captain
Quint that was the pirate Weeble uh one
was uh [__] the guy who just had the
W on her shirt and [__] that was my uh
Brody Chief Brody Weeble and then there
was one who had glasses that was my Matt
Hooper Weebles so I bring those Weebles
to life man they they years later they
made different Weebles which don't look
like
the real Weebles as far as I'm concerned
those are the three Man Mark you go and
I'm gonna go grab my [__] uh I'm afraid
that I don't have nearly as uh tied a
bond to my childhood toys the way Kev
does
um
I mean I the the first real toys toys
that I remember getting were Star Wars
figures
um
Star Wars and GI Joe
I was never uh you know perished the
thought I was never a huge He-Man guy I
mean I had a few He-Man figures but I
was never
um that was not the one that I went deep
on
I think I went dude you wrote [__] on
a goddamn He-Man show you better say
he-man
we were actually too old for He-Man yeah
He-Man just it missed me you know in
that in that sort of demographic Zone I
was not that kid I wanted the toys but
my parents were like we did Star Wars
we're not starting a whole other [__]
thing for you yeah you are done now yes
but I think if I could put anything in
in the in the cupboard and have it come
to life and then roll around with me
pocket-sized because they're not gonna
be like [__] life-sized they're this
big he said they would put Snake Eyes
from uh from GI Joe in there because who
couldn't use a pocket-sized ninja
like just to solve problems man like
it's like my bodyguard but in your
pocket it doesn't say a lot but you can
talk to and it's just nod it's like yeah
man like no I get you I feel you like
yeah you just you're mute that's okay
um but I can slice anybody you need me
to slice
um so yeah I go I go I go snake eyes
that's a [__] Weeble that's a Weeble
right there kids and that's the [__]
that was the Weeble who played Roy
Scheider in my version of Jaws
this is the Snoopy SST cycle this one
don't break apart so he's got Woodstock
in the back but the Snoopy actually
comes out and stuff he's got like a
bottom so you could work him like a
finger puppet if your fingers are very
small like a child
legless Snoopy so if you go like this
it's all good you go like this it's
horrifying but he you put him in the
cycle and [__] and then you [__] yank
it back and you turn the handle and you
press the click and it went across the
floor and [__] this though is not my
original little man but this is what the
little man looked like
wow if his head could come off this
one's secured [__] but I pick his head
off and I pretend he was the Invisible
Man this [__] and again not this
exact one my real little man is lost to
the ages but a little man that looked
exactly like this
spent so much time in my hand as a child
and shout out to my brother Donald
we were at my uh grandparents house in
Edison New Jersey was it Edison
no I think my it wasn't where where was
it Hillside at the hillside that's what
it is
um
past
whatever [__] now I'm deep in the weeds
of New Jersey but in any event we're at
my grandparents house and by the
staircase up to my grandparents house
was a tiny [__] crevice
where the wall met the [__] doorway
and [__] and he fit into this [__]
crevice and my brother you know this is
gonna ain't gonna make anybody [__]
laugh but I this would make me cry
laughter as a child and I'm talking five
years old my brother would put him in
that little crevice and he would sing
I'm in my little corner of the world and
oh my God that was the funniest thing
ever so have you ever liked clerks or
[__] Mall Rats or any of the comedies
I ever did it begins with my brother
singing I'm in my little corner of the
world with my little man right there
he's meant to be wearing a hat kids
because back in the day McDonald's
employees wore little hats like that
technology yeah
what a [__] wonderful walk down
memory lane that was for me I know a
bunch of people were like good God but
yeah BJ Fisher in chat mentioned the Six
Million Dollar Man toy which I remember
like I had one of those with the little
discs that you could slide in his
[__] head into well his bionics were
in his arm you could take the bionics
off you could look through the eye and
the hole in the back of his head for a
bionic Wyatt had a magnifying eye and
[__] and his arm would go click click
click click came with a motor engine
like the engine of a [__] car that he
could lift up and stuff and he had roll
down skin to cover his bionics yep
I had all those [__] dolls man I had
Six Million Dollar Man I had Oscar
Goldman and the exploding briefcase at
the rocket that [__] you could do
operations on [__] Six Million Dollar
Man and yes I had Jamie Summers man of
course I've loved it all that's
dedication
see Mark stole my thunder because I was
gonna say I would put my Six Million
Dollar Man in there and then the only
other thing I would put in well probably
my GI joke because that poor thing went
through hell and back he deserves a
chance to live and interact with other
things but the last thing I would put in
this nobody's gonna know these but my
dad used to work for the company that
made heavy construction equipment
Komatsu so he would always go away on a
business trip or when they would get new
models their little die-cast models of
their older units he would be able to
bring them home for me so I would put
them in there so that way they could be
a little mechanical Army for The Bionic
Man and and GI Joe with one leg and and
drawing all over his head I just know if
they came to life though they would just
judge me
they were like why dilf man pretty much
this is what you became we had such hope
for you
somebody mentioned in chat that is uh
and endless music said Planet of the
Apes was my jam
shout out to every Migo doll
ever made if I had a joker Migo doll I
wanted I had a general erko or ursus
Amigo doll I wanted [__] all the Migo
dolls but like generally any mego doll I
had was a hand me down or something I
found in the garbage yes I was a garbage
picker
um but man oh man
uh
the Migo owned my childhood
they had the defining toys because we
all grew up on reruns of Batman and
Robin and those were the main Migos
anyways he ain't lying just man ain't
lying kids excellent
um all right
last question last question well we'll
see if it's last because Super Chat
might [__] pay to ask a question
everybody else that was spending money
fell asleep
I'm gonna get talked to later uh Adam
hold on man Brian Christian chat said
Tonka toy trucks
that's for the rich kids
I remembered a commercial it's a Tonka
toy attack a toy built Tonka Strong
build Tonka tough just for fun fun
part of my [__] childhood as well I
had a couple tongues but I wouldn't put
them in the cupboard because then you
just get a small truck
no magic there which is a tiny truck
without a driver well now I gotta ask
you know what I put in that cupboard my
dead father
he said he could come back
I put that urn in the closet and then
he'd be like let me the [__] out where's
the rest of me I'd be like in an urn
that looks like dolphin's Dad too long
to explain but there's some dignity here
stick a Monchichi in there and just ask
it why do you exist wow what a deep cut
that is
oh so soft and cuddly
yeah see look a bunch of never mind we
got we got Jingles kids When We Were
Young we didn't just have toys we had
Jingles so if you couldn't afford the
toys you could at least sing the jingles
uh Adam kimmelman
from the chat asked you're tasked to
read make The Odd Couple but with genre
characters
who's your neat freak feeling well we
know who the people are but who's your
Felix singer and who's your Oscar
Madison
so Felix has to be fastidious
and Oscar has to be kind of like a slob
well I mean I guess
Todd McFarland did it with Sam and
twitch right
they kind of fit that mold but
let's see who would be mine
Linus Van Pelt
would be my Felix
um
pig pen
oh my oscar I'd go right to the [__]
peanuts kids right to those depressed
peanuts children it was Depression era
urchins I just I was talking I think I
was talking to my brother about it when
I was back in Florida but I was like
it's crazy to me that [__] the
peanuts aren't as big now as when we
were children because now kids are
really depressed
like you know Charles Schultz was a
middle-aged man or you know at least an
adult when he was doing little folks and
like all these stories about like
[__] the first I don't know who I was
talking about I'm John Gordon I think my
friend first time I ever heard the term
psychiatric
was [__] from the peanuts and that
was I was like six years old I was like
how do you pronounce this word my sister
was like psychiatric I was like what
does that mean she's like that's a head
doctor for people who are crazy and you
know Charles Schultz was like way ahead
of his time in terms of like he drew
cute characters but they were sassy as
[__] one of the first the first
strip of Little Folks
which is what became peanuts in the home
of Charlie Brown there's a there's a I
forget which characters are sitting
there and like Derek Here Comes Charlie
Brown good old Charlie Brown there's
Charlie Brown and the last panel was the
kids going God I hate him
shit's dark very dark so I choose Lions
Van Pelt and I choose Pig Pen only
because a it works and B because I'm
gonna try to keep peanuts love alive man
did you ever see uh it was the thing
that swept the internet for all of half
an hour like five or six years ago but
it was Garfield without Garfield yeah
just like pulled Garfield out of just
John having existential crises standing
over the kitchen
saying things to nothing
expressing things to nothing yes oh my
God that was wonderful
boy that pulls me back to the early days
of the internet there was also it was
like peanuts minus one where they would
always pull the last frame out of
peanuts so we just give you the three
panels set up but not the joke at the
end and then it's just a bunch of sad
depressed children
as an old-time peanuts fan
that sounds good strong strong word
um I think I go with uh with heck McCoy
as your Felix Unger
and uh and Logan as your your mat your
Oscar Madison I think it's beast and
Wolverine but Beast is the neat freak
Beast is a fastidious one and then
Wolverine just has [__] beard cans
everywhere and just [__] in the woods he
doesn't care excellent [__] in the woods
when is he [__] [__] in the woods I
mean it wouldn't surprise me if he had
cut out of Logan what are you doing
Logan [__] in the woods man I don't
know excellent [__] pull good times
on that
um
um and enlist music said what is the Fat
Man on Batman runtime record or fat man
Beyond rather runtime record I don't
know question definitely three hours
we've done three hours before we've done
three apps we've done three hours like
standing at the bar
um ooh this is two dollars in super chat
but it's [__] worth talking about
recovery unplugged says hi Kevin I'm a
mental health advocate uh so am I in a
big bad way
um more now than I've ever been in my
life but more on that later in the
coming weeks or if you want to join that
Kevin Smith Club you can hear some
meditations
oh my God you're amazing thank you for
helping me [__] sell that if you join
that Kevin Smith club kids which is like
my patreon or whatever the [__] I used
to do a show called wake and bake there
because I smoke weed and would smoke
weed and [__] Chit Chat uh but since
I don't smoke weed anymore
um I I felt like calling it wake and
bake was weird and then for a while I
was like well we could change it to this
we could change it to that uh but as of
this morning I launched wake and bake is
finished last episode I did was me
talking about my mom being in the
hospital and [__] uh but now the show is
called meditations
uh where we talk about mental health
amongst other things and whatnot uh you
can join that Kevin Smith club and watch
that show all you want it's on Mondays
Wednesdays and Fridays and in a world
where you're [__] overpaying for
Super Chat my God
go join that Kevin Smith club's way
cheaper and you'll get answers fast
um is that is that it
I mean I mean unless you're gonna
suddenly try and invoke the Super Chat
gods and Rise raise them what happens to
the super chatters
that like went away like that we
some a donkey show the donkey that dorky
review show says why did Kevin stop
smoking weed I missed that episode I've
talked about it before
um especially right here
um it's too long to go into but long
story short you know I've just uh I'd
like to be present and weed was
wonderful for 15 years straight but it
allowed me to be present while not being
present at all and now I just wanna
be present Nico gave us 53.90 of some
currency which I don't recognize just to
give us a goddamn thumbs up [__] a
man
to answer your question Kevin I can I
can show you a different interface that
you can work from where you can see all
of them I'm looking at them all right
now
is that right yeah man how come I don't
have that because you're scared of new
things
you ain't wrong
because that's why there's a clerks
three as opposed to like anything new
yeah I don't I don't got any Super
Chatters man
I used to although Josh mundahl just
jumped in once again
Josh spent like 500 tonight don't do
that Josh he says but we cannot have a
direct chat with you on the club side
Kevin so this is the direct way to
communicate with you and Mark my brother
he's right but you can have a direct
chat with me because now I'm going to
start going into the what's it called
will the Discord
thank you will oh you got a Discord yeah
he's got it all club members can go to
the Discord and there is an AKA channel
in there so ask Kev anything and will is
going to teach me how to use the Discord
so I could [__] jump in there and
and play you seem to teach you but
really it's just like here log in here
click this go it's it's it's nothing man
well I I don't [__] learn from
Reading will I I need to be taught a
[__] thing told the thing by a person
it's case in point I ain't read a
[__] book in years you could tell by
my language that must be the case you
know what I just note I just discovered
no
[__] wait hold on hold on I have
personally sold advertising space on
this podcast
I know I just never listen to them I
listen to my own audiobook once when I
recorded it and [__] and they sent it to
me it's like all right that sounds like
me but Scott Moser uh was like you know
what book you've got to read uh the
courage to be disliked is that what the
title is hold on I want to say it I want
to get it right
it's called the courage to be disliked
and it's written by
uh [__] I can't oh
shishimi is that right close enough yeah
good enough and
fumataki Koga
um
the Japanese
phenomenon that shows you how to change
your life
and Achieve real happiness so you know
Mojo's like you should read this and I'm
like bro you know me I'm [__] I never
got time to read a goddamn book and [__]
like that that's never gonna happen and
he's like why don't you just listen to
it and I was like a [__] newfangled
listen to they've only had books on tape
for the last like [__] 40 years and
[__] so I I [__] joined Audible and
I'm you know I go hiking running every
day and I'm in the car a lot I always
listen to the same 100 [__] songs
over and over and over again now all of
a sudden I'm listening to this book I'm
on chapter [__] 30. like this is
amazing I know it's a free commercial
for audible but [__] it I'm loving the
[__] out of this book the courage to be
just like and I don't know if you can
say I've read a book anymore if somebody
says it to you but I'm learning can you
yeah
account so I could be like I read it
even though I didn't you ingested the
content of the book good enough for me
man
um the Rob Brown Channel says Kevin
Smith writer discovers books
I've been busy making [__] so I stopped
reading [__] and whatnot but this gives
me a chance to like go hiking and not
[__] listen to the same 100 songs
over and over again now I'm [__]
listening to this book and there's
something oddly comforting about
somebody reading a book and I also
cognize a lot better somebody's saying
[__] to me rather than me reading it
most of the [__] I would read would just
be lost on me and [__] and now instead
I'm [__] I can rewind it and be like
what did they [__] say this book has
taught me so many good things man the
courage to be disliked so yes I'm I
don't know how I got started on this
thread but I don't either but I I will
also say that most of the books that I
have quote unquote read for the last
five years or so have been audiobooks is
that right yeah because I'm in the car a
lot and like I used to listen to lots of
podcasts but like people will send me
books like hey do you want to like maybe
think about adapting this you're gonna
take a run at this or I wrote a book or
whatever it is it's like great and
download it right away and start
listening to it because when I had a
train commute on the East Coast I used
to read a lot but without a train and
just in my car that was just dead time
and so that's become the way I like
begin to ingest [__] and he's the
smartest guy on this [__] show kids
we all know that so if Mark [__]
advocates for listening to a book then
God damn it listening to a book we shall
um I've been loving it believe me this
ain't the last book I'm going to listen
to now I'm going to listen to more books
because that's how I [__] learn
you're an auditory learner not a visual
learner
see if I was the smartest guy in the
show I would have said that 10 minutes
uh Josh munshall paid 999 stop [__]
paying money Josh to say this oh by the
way for God in Jersey He-Man was the
bomb yo Transcendental Meditation will
help a lot with mental health and
happiness sobriety is a daily Choice
you've got more support than you realize
that's very [__] sweet thank you
recovery unplugged jump back into 10
bucks and say this is Amy will you be
able to be at my letters to Daniel
screening it's my castle May 19th 7 PM
she's gonna get a free commercial out of
this
um Amy did this uh uh flip called
letters to Daniel which she's bringing
to smog Castle as you heard on May 19th
uh 7 P.M why let me check my calendar
Amy well not let me agree she spent 30
bucks overall the shape
May 19th
I believe I may be there
I believe I may be there Amy
um
letters to Daniel kids come see it it's
modcastle Cinemas at May 19th tickets
that's my castlecinemas.com
uh and good seeing you again Amy but
don't don't we know each other don't
[__] pay me to ask what to say things
especially to say nice things like that
um
Keith says with super chats we will be
here five hours
I don't think uh I don't think anyone
wants that so what we should wrap up I
think we should
although Corey Gilmartin just spent five
bucks to say this hey Kev had a blast at
the John Wick 4 screening at smodcast of
last Saturday he was there to watch
quick with Kev thanks for staying after
to talk with me and Katie uh so hype for
Guardians 3 and 4 20. yeah man when is
Guardians open uh May 40th yeah first
weekend in May
May 4th I gotta see if I'm gonna be
there for that because I definitely want
to [__]
do that like that's how we get to do the
merry Marvel movie Society since I can't
show the old [__] you gotta do there and
[__] if that have you seen that little
piece they put up online the like
you know [__] uh bunch of the cast
sitting there talking about like how
this is the end and [__] you know
it's like interview footage mixed with
the trailer all of them [__] talk
about like bring tissues man like it's
all [__] heart in this one around I
can't wait I want James Gunn to make me
cry so badly
you can call me a masochist I don't give
a [__]
yeah oh no [__] the trailer makes me
emotion well may the fourth you're there
for revenge of the Smith that's all I
can tell you
and when does when does this open May
4th oh [__] so I'm gonna be there
uh apparently so
guess what we'll be adding to the
schedule guess what your community
I will be flying there
um Guardians of the Galaxy the same as
Star Wars Day says Brian Christian in
chat there you go I'll be there for that
[__] man can't wait I saw a trailer at
um
San Diego Comic-Con last year when they
did the [__] you know marvel panel
and [__] which they've never released
one to The Flaming Lips do you realize
was like one of my favorite things I've
ever seen
in my [__] life
um that made it very emotional but
[__] every trailer they've put
together
since you've been gone [__] trailer
like
I can't wait James Gunn gonna make gonna
make us all cry
and I'm here for it uh kids
have you enjoyed does Kev know that
YouTube takes a cut of Super Chat says
they told me earlier in the [__]
in the broadcast man I mean what you're
going does it matter yes
excellent point dilfman it's free money
kids for those who hate my films don't
worry I'm gonna give up filmmaking
because this Super Chat [__]
that's where my future lies
answered questions for money that's what
I used to do q and A's for Years anyway
so now we just get to do it from home uh
thank you for all you super Chatters who
came and threw money at us and [__] like
that uh we can afford to pay people like
will Wilkins dilfman himself
thanks to your large yes
um thanks for everyone else even the
people that didn't [__] pay for Super
Chat and you don't have to pay for Super
Chat kids
um I'm sure when this show is done I'm
gonna get talked to by a hundred people
who are like stop it and I do bad idea
yeah you're gonna kill the show and I
said we killed the show a long time ago
nobody's coming they're coming for
Austin
is that right we have Austin alone
he's my boy that's my son for God's
sakes and actually as he pointed out uh
because he texted me be like don't
[__] credit me with Super Chat the
one who credited the one who deserves
the credit for me knowing about Super
Chat was my kid who paid Peter sharetta
and his [__] Disney you know his I
love Disney show him and his lady I
don't know what it's called I'm not
doing it justice but she told me she was
like I paid ten dollars to ask a
question on Super Chat and I was like
wait a second what and she described
what it is and I was like you can do
this [__] now and so today in Austin is
Harley who introduced me to Super Chat
um
there it is kids did you enjoy
yourselves I [__] had a good ass time
if we keep this going for another 10
minutes it'll be a four hour [__]
show
I can't do it
Jason just gave us five bucks in Super
Chat to say I just got clerks three the
ending got me teary eyed boy thank you
I've been living with for months now
people on Twitter uh saying respectfully
[__] you uh because I made them
emotional with uh clerks three uh you're
welcome uh have you enjoyed yourselves
as much as I did well if you did is
because of the guy [__] I never do it
right the guy right there kids
I [__] without the smartest man on
[__] or woman on [__] fat man
beyond kids is Mark Bernard this show
ain't nothing without the great Mark
madard and give it up for Mark Bernard
and everybody thank you everybody
um and uh this week my God
proving that [__] he don't know [__]
about Star Wars like [__] Banff man
but God damn it if he didn't produce the
[__] out of this show uh give it up for
[__] dilf man dilf in here
hello
thank you I appreciate it I'm just
ladies and gentlemen I'm very sales
oriented I guess
rightfully so somebody got to be
speaking of sales kids are you in Los
Angeles come see me and Mark Bernardin
no no no no me and Mark Bernard when we
figure out when that show is going to be
but this Saturday come see me Ralph
Garmin doing Hollywood Babylon you want
to see me and Mark Bernard in New Jersey
you go to smartcastlecinemas.com right
now go to the coming soon section
tickets on sale for the August what is
it 25th August 25th fat man beyond and
on August 26th there may or may not be
keep calm and Curry on but it's on sale
now so I don't know what the [__]
Ernie's talking about
um
come see us for heaven's sakes come to
smog Castle Cinemas I'm coming there all
throughout the next few weeks man don't
forget 420 Jane Sal and Bob reboot 421
trailer park 422 is sold out it's
Chasing Amy with Jason Lee
and then revenge of the Smith on May 5th
but I'm going to be there now for
[__] May 4th for Guardians of the
[__] Galaxy and [__] like that watch
that with Keb
um uh what else are we doing May 6th is
uh Jay and Silent Bob Strike Back with
Jason Muse May 7th is drawing flies with
Malcolm Ingram and Jason Muse May 28th
is [__] Jersey Girl the the Snyder
cut
what what the [__] what's IDR 50 000
what [__] what Indonesian
50 000 we're Rich I just wanted to be
like rupals we could quit the show fifty
thousand eight cat fan from Indonesia
here when are we going to get the
continuation of the Batman movie
commentaries they're hilarious what a
great question yeah 50 000 whatever that
is you're gonna get a goddamn answer
when will it be Mark uh it could be
whenever you want it to be Kim I think
all we have to do is uh we had Dark
Knight and Dark Knight Rises
and then we're done is that right and
then the Batman if we want to go all the
way through
I'm sorry did that
did you guys see my face
I mean
how about how about we'll do the first
two hours of the Batman but then like
there's a flood out of nowhere like
[Music]
yes
the Sandman comes in and pulls them off
oh deep Cuts wonderful
um no somebody Warrior fellas that
somebody really just gave away 50k uh no
because as Roberto Hoyas points out it's
3.36 but still that 50 000 was an
impressive looking [__] number
um kids
there you go you wanted some fat man
beyond you got it and it wouldn't
[__] stop at all
uh 336
3.36 seconds 36 Cents that's what that
fifty thousand IDR number is we don't
give a [__] money's money and money no
YouTube took 30 of that but I don't give
a [__]
and this went long strong because we're
down to get the friction on
Baby Got Back
uh there it is kids [__] uh we'll be
back uh with episodes what is it three
three
and four hundred
you better bet that episode 400 is going
to happen in the next two weeks and it's
gonna happen at [__]
scum and villainy cantina and then the
only question is whether 399 is an
in-person show or a [__] one of these
things
but now that [__] Super Chat exists
I'm never going back to the [__]
401 to 500 is back on the Super Chat
Mark ain't lying man don't don't don't
don't be shocked if I just do a whole
ass Super Chat Show
Kevin Super Chat a love story and just
everybody want to create a podcast
called Kev Super Chat and that's all
we're gonna do
throw me a shekel throw me a [__] two
bits throw me 50 000 of whatever that
was for 3.36 and I'll answer your
goddamn question awesome coin to your
Smither yeah
uh there it is my friends uh for fat man
beyond
um I'm Kevin Smith and I am Mark Bernard
tune in next time same Super Chat Time
same
Super Chat Channel
podcast.com or youtube.com Kevin Smith a
super chatty Jeff's kiss to you all
right
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin
it's all well at the end of the show
Bob get old off Kevin Smith
foreign